a diagnosis or something he's he's not
he's he he's Frank that the
abnormalities that are shown in the fmri
can't be
um
on the Imaging alone traced back to the
ski accident or even just a concussion
but he says given the fmri and given the
other evidence that he thinks the fmri
abnormalities are connected to the
concussion or the ski accident
concussion and how is he determining
abnormalities
uh on the fmri uh by reference to a kind
of normal database okay similar to his
own yes his own okay great thank you
yeah
Mr Bueller
good morning good morning
um
in summary Council for the defendant is
late and incorrect they're late they
should have done this months ago but on
the first point on the 2009 fmri on page
on page 39 of Dr Gibby's deposition
line well it doesn't have line numbers
on it the defense is uh court reporter
doesn't give us lines but it's the
second to the last line
and in fact if you go back
even further in the medical record back
to about 2009 he clearly has Imaging
Evidence of normal pressure encephalitis
hydrocephalus mph
and that's we brought that up in opening
uh Dr Gibby
the defense brings it up all the time Dr
uh Gibby mentioned it again I'll just go
to the page 39 he says this is Dr Gibby
that doesn't mean he's symptomatic from
it it doesn't mean a lot of people in
fact there are people that are Rhodes
Scholars that if you look back in some
of the early literature on hydrocephalus
these people function at very high
levels so what did he review a radiology
report or did it it's the 2009 Radiology
report that the defense is relying on to
say
uh Terry Sanderson I'm talking about
your expert now is he was he looking at
a radiology report or the film itself
I think both is he is he going to be
offering anything in addition to what
you just read well there's it goes on it
goes on I'm just the the main factor
that they did not
uh they first they bring it up late and
so it's hard for us to respond on
literally no notice
um second day of trial and clearly
they're incorrect that he
discussed it in his deposition they said
just said he didn't discuss it so what
you're reading from is a discovery
deposition correct and
and where he's disclosing his opinions
saying that the NPH
doesn't mean he had all these problems
if he did he wouldn't even be skiing he
couldn't even drive he would be
incontinent couldn't control his muscles
and he would have dementia and that is
not true that you know he did not have
any of those symptoms
prior to the crash after the crash he
doesn't have those because he he's not
in a he's not symptomatic of mph he's
symptomatic of a brain concussion I'm
more concerned with just disclosure of
the 2009 MRI that it formed a basis for
his opinion yeah he references it the
defense had it Dr Gibby had it and was
discussing it now if the defense the
third um
and James just remind me what your
second point was the condition of the
ventricle's opinion
um
yeah causation
those concussive symptoms were
able yeah again this is relate and uh
incorrect or inaccurate at best uh Dr
Gibby in his deposition
discuss these things now I'm not sure I
don't think the defense closed the loop
on Dr Gibby if they don't ask him is
this all your opinions about NPH he
mentions mph is this all your opinions
about the condition of the ventricles I
don't think they close the loop on that
finally the fmri he discusses his his uh
um I mean the defense could have brought
a motion on fmri
months ago like they should have with Dr
Fong but um again he uses the fmri and
it's rock solid he Dr Gibby happens to
be one of the foremost experts on using
the fmri he has one of the foremost uh
fmri MRI machines in the world is he
going to offer an opinion uh that relies
on his normative database
I don't know I'm not sure it's necessary
because he was looking at Terry
sanderson's X-rays of his chest and
determining what he was doing but he did
not use the fmri for diagnosis which is
I think the key point and uh
no we are maybe it's in the courtroom is
does everyone good with that I'm fine
with it okay he's an expert Legacy New
York well this is our go ahead Mr
Bueller thank you your honor
um the point is
not only is a very very late I mean
second day of trial but it's totally
incorrect what they've said on all three
points
and the tooth you know I could read more
about the um
what Dr Bain says uh because it's just
inaccurate that he didn't discuss it in
his deposition and it's inaccurate to
say that they somehow that the defense
can exclude this because he didn't
discuss it in his deposition
and I don't think the defense closed the
loop say is this all of your opinions I
don't think they closed that Loop if
they don't ask them if they go through
his background and his some of his
opinions that doesn't mean he didn't
have other opinions and he can also
rebut the defense's claims that NPH was
the cause of Terry sanderson's problems
can you respond to the to the argument
that has con that it did he did State a
conclusion regarding the origin of the
post-concussive symptoms
but he qualified it saying that it was
speculative I I I'd like to see the site
because they've been inaccurate before
and it's hard for us to respond on no
notice to something that I don't know
what they're talking about and uh you
know just you know this is sandbagging
at its best and I don't mean to cast an
aspersion but is this it's not unusual
to have these these issues raised at
trial you know they've known about
giving testifying for months uh actually
years he was properly disclosed two
years ago and they've waited until this
moment I think it's you know I I can I'm
not going to guess why they're doing it
this last moment but that's true on the
fmri we just proved that they are
incorrect on pages 38 and 39 and I
believe it goes uh to 40.
um I think you've convinced me on that
point and the uh so on the point number
two I'd just like to have a citation
where does he say this so we can respond
to it I can't find speculative in the
deposition and then finally on fmri
they never tested him like they tested
Dr Fong into her deposition
um eight days ago okay thank you Mr Egan
just briefly I want to get the jury in
here yes
so you're on just first uh on the point
about whether Dr Gibby reviewed the 2009
MRI images on page uh let's see on page
65 of his
opinion or his uh nope sorry on page
it's 85. of his deposition he says I
have not been able to personally inspect
images pre-accident no one has ever
provided those to me he says he's just
seen the reports on the next page and
then on page
861 he says I'm speculating honestly
that perhaps the reason that he had
Persistence of this longer is that he
has these underlying stiff ventricles
which didn't allow his brain to give way
which the pressure you know
water if you take a depth chart and you
put it into water it sends it I could go
on but that that's the basic idea 60
two 61 into 62.
I'm simply hypothesizing that because of
the increased amounts of CSF in here
that the brain is already stretched and
you slam into the snow and decelerate
that you produce an injury
and then
um
I in terms of this question about
whether we locked them in I told him at
the very start of the deposition my
purpose today is to be as efficient as I
can in exhausting your testimony I think
that was clear
um
so that's what I'm saying okay thank you
well as to the the MRI I think Dr Gibby
can certainly rely on the on the
Radiology report
um it sounds like you didn't review The
Imaging and I don't know that you were
planning to have him offer any new
opinions after having reviewed the
Imaging but if there are any new
opinions those who would I would sustain
an objection to those there are no new
opinions but uh
Dr sander Terry sanderson's
Imaging the images can be looked at Dr
Gibby has looked at them because he was
provided them afterwards if if not
before
[Music]
the deposition doesn't you know just
because you know I'm going to ask you
all of your opinions eventually but the
deposition ends and they they don't ask
them all is it all of his opinions that
doesn't mean it's not the duty of the
witness to uh correct the defense
councils
failure to do that
so again no no new opinions related to
the 2009 Imaging I mean the images
themselves as opposed to the Radiology
report which he said he relied on but he
hadn't seen the Imaging and so any if he
were to offer any new opinions those
would be not disclosed at this point on
the Imaging itself
okay but uh the report because he does
have those images now any references I
mean if it's pointed out on
cross-examination that isn't it true
that you haven't haven't evaluated these
images I mean that may open the door to
something but as far as direct
examination you can't offer any new
opinions on the 2009 Imaging of course
again no new opinions or say that he has
reviewed the images
that
under it I think is important because
otherwise they're yeah they're mudding
the water right I understand and I
appreciate
all the council giving me their
arguments but I'd like to funnel it
through just one Council on each side
concerning the opinion on cause
if if there's an objection that an
opinion is speculative that'll be
sustained I mean if if it's not offered
to a reasonable degree of medical
probability it's not proper so any
opinions need to have that as a
foundation
and then finally on the fmri if Dr Gibby
is going to rely on a normative database
or I'm calling it that I don't know what
you might or he might call it but a
database of functional MRI imaging so
that he can compare the plaintiff's
Imaging to this database I think I I
believe you understand the requirements
under rule 702 to establish reliability
first and if you do that it may come in
or it would if if he's able to convince
the court that there's sufficient
reliability for those for that using
that database then that can come in
I think that
I mean I'm not going to tell you how to
try your case but that probably should
happen outside of the hearing of the
jury if you're planning on going in that
direction
your honor since this came up even
though it's been known for years what
his deposition said
um in the uh I would ask that we have a
five-minute
time period to have a conference with Dr
Gibby
and then outside of the presence of the
jury we readdress this issue because I
know he's I think he's probably reviewed
his deposition he knows his testimony
his opinions haven't changed they just
end up regarding speculation well there
are risk factors for concussion you can
mph
I think
excess fluid in those ventricles makes
you more susceptible to a concussion so
it's a risk factor it's not speculation
it is just a risk factor
and I mean I think I gave my ruling so
if if
you know he shouldn't be offering
opinions that aren't supported by a
reasonable degree of medical probability
and I understand your the Nuance having
to do with risk of actors and he may be
able to offer that opinion if he can do
so to a reasonable degree of medical
certainty
and just just let me just finish or you
know close the circle on this one so we
will we can take a short recess if you
could let the jury know that we're
working on some issues and it'll be a
little bit longer
um and then if you if you decide after
speaking with your expert that you will
be I guess tendering some of these
issues or the issue regarding the fmri
database then you can then I'll
certainly give you some time outside of
the hearing of the journey to try to lay
a foundation for that
thank you Mr Owens your honor we have a
new camera pointed directly at my client
right there on the right which we
understand is from the AP
this is a
during the recess I'll have the court
representative Tanya take a look at how
that camera's pointed and make sure that
it's pointed at the lectern rather than
at the council table
it's been a problem where
for instance reporters being in front of
my client's car going out yesterday uh
cameras in her face like Angels who went
up during the recess with Tanya and
talked to her about that I've already
talked to her about the fact that you've
raised this issue yesterday and and I
recognize it as a problem and I want to
be advised if there are new changes
because it's just by chance that we see
that there's a camera pointed directly
at her which is contrary to the decorum
order so I don't want changes without
reporters telling you
that's a reasonable request so thank you
we'll take a short recess and if you
could let the bailiff know as soon as
you're ready Mr Bueller
thank you
for the record I didn't do this earlier
this is Sanderson versus Paltrow
190-50048 and Council are all present
uh Mr Owens
uh the camera that I reference was a
violation of the decorum order that's
the second violation in two days
directly still photographer directly on
my client's face already transmitted
nationally
so I'm mad
the the Quorum order we spent a lot of
time on
it's the Court's order people are
subject to criminal sanction and
I want it to stop I don't want to have
to be the one raising it I want them to
comply
the camera's been removed
as far as what's going on in the parking
lot that's I'm not I'm not going to
conflate that with this photographer
who's doing something differently the
the what's going on in the parking lot
is uh
Tanya's has worked with your staff in
determining how to handle the parking
lot Transitions and I think that's been
smoothed out in terms of violation of
the Court's decorum order and and have
the camera pointing where it's not
supposed to be pointing I mean
essentially cameras are supposed to
follow the microphone
this is a what's what the court has
permitted is media coverage of the
proceeding not of the individuals who
aren't participating in the proceeding
when they're not participating so if
you're speaking into a microphone you
can expect that an image may be captured
if you're not speaking into a microphone
you shouldn't you should not be
expecting that an image would be
captured
um
and I do I do see this as a violation
and I've asked that that the that the
reporter be told that this is now
interrupting our proceedings it's now
interfering with our proceedings having
to deal with these issues and if it
happens again the offending reporter
will be asked to leave
great and our the still photographer is
to stay in his seat when taking pictures
is that right stay in his location
unless we're all standing
then they can stand and take a picture
how about entering and exiting
can they be in the path of my client no
thank you I have a new issue which is
this uh
beheading in front of me may I sure this
this was laid on our desk just now
we did get a picture of it
day before Dr Fong was deposed which was
eight days ago we got a pitcher
your honor they're they're intending to
have Dr Gibby talk about it this brain
has lots of different pieces and
everything this was not at his
deposition
we haven't had our experts review this
we've never seen it in a
three-dimensional format until this
what's your objection
untimely disclosure okay thank you thank
you was this disclosed as a
demonstrative exhibit yes it's not going
to the jury it's just a and how is it
disclosed as a demonstrating pictures of
it he said come over and look at it if
he wants and that was just before Fong's
deposition okay
yeah I'll sustain the objection if it
wasn't disclosed under rule under the
guidelines required by rule 26.
I mean you know there's no objection to
that so well I mean what's good for the
goose is good for the gander I mean all
he wants to do is use this use this to
explain as I understand Mr Sykes and it
may be perfectly fine but he's objected
to it and the rule wasn't followed and
so I must uphold the rule
and do we do we need to are we ready for
the jury or would you like to examine
your witness out of the hearing of the
jury
I was hearing of the jury but I'd just
like to remind the core or inform the
court which was not uh mentioned earlier
by the defense is that uh
at uh before Dr Gibby's deposition
several years ago or
the uh are we still on the demonstrative
exhibit no we're on the fmri okay go
ahead his uh Vita curriculum or his
resume
discloses his Publications
peer-reviewed I assume one is uh
oral presentation Advanced fmri for the
clinician Baylor University oral
presentation Advanced applications
2015 20 you know these are 2015-2016.
I'll let him get into it to lay the
foundation
sure that the court is not misled to
think that we're hiding something or
something's coming in at the last moment
this was disclosed
depositions which was
um
and it's nothing new
August 4th of 2021 plus they have the
depth of the
in the initial disclosure which is
probably several months before that so
it's almost
on your second day of trial they object
but we would like to lay the foundation
for the fmri discussion that Dr thanks
Gibby will have during his presentation
okay
you may proceed
right here on your way there
swear that the testimony you are about
to give in the case now before the court
will be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you God
thank you
good morning
you're you're laying the foundation but
would you state your full name and spell
it for the record please Wendell Harlan
Gibby
w-e-n-d-e-l-l-a-r-l-e-n-g-i-b-b-y
ear honor if I may instead of going
through the long background in education
could I do an abbreviated one or
whatever you feel you need to support
your request that this
witness be able to talk about his
database okay uh Dr Gibby we'll go into
it later but can you uh quickly tell the
court of your background and uh training
and where you are right now and the work
you're doing in neuroradiology and
what's related to your testimony today
yes thank you I'm a medical doctor
trained at University of Utah
residency and Diagnostic Radiology at
University of Arizona a fellowship in in
neuroradiology at the University of
Pennsylvania
and I am currently an Adjunct professor
of radiology at University of California
San Diego I have a private practice of
radiology in Provo Utah
next I'd like to uh
just focus in for now on the fmri
that
the discussion that we'd like to present
the jury today
tell us about the foundation or the
reliability or The Quirk that's gone
into your sort of fmri and if you could
explain it for the court so we have a
clear picture
so functional MRI involves a technique
wherein we look at the activation of the
brain it's
it was first described in the 1990s
where it
um
as the brain consumes oxygen it changes
the signal intensity of the brain with
very subtle changes in the magnetic
field the local magnetic field and using
this technique uh
doctors around the world have applied it
to a variety of techniques I think the
first application we used was back in
about
1997 or so when we would use
exercises or finger tapping while the
patient was in the scanner to identify
the motor cortex
for neurosurgeons
this technique has evolved over the
years to identify different areas of
brain activation
um
we moved ahead and in approximately 15
years ago started doing quantitative
functional MRI where we would evaluate
the activation of different areas of the
brain during standard
neuropsychological testing and along
that way we developed atlases which you
can see in my CV have been presented at
various conferences and
normative database or controls with
patients that we perform questionnaires
to exclude other medical problems and
created
age related
normally control database for six or
seven different neuropsychological tests
would it be helpful your honor if we
show his Vita on the screen or I don't
have a hard copy to show you right now
to show his Vita her resume or a
curriculum what did we call it here
CV CV I mean if it would be in some
assistance to you that's fine well to
establish the foundation because this is
what was challenged earlier and uh we uh
we we want to make sure it's helpful to
the court so I understood you were
making a threshold showing under rule
702 b as to the reliability okay
the
what is it about your testimony today
about this case involving Terry
sanderson's brain injuries
that demonstrate the reliability of your
use of the fmri in his case I know
that's a broad question but that kind of
cuts to the chase
well I think that that
I'm not an attorney and I'm not under
I'm not sure I understand rule 702 but I
do know from a scientific perspective in
order for data to be valid you have to
have controls it has to be reproducible
you have to perform
statistical testing on this or standard
deviations because all people have
there's a range of normal
and you can't
um you can't use it to make
um assumptions or to draw conclusions
beyond what the data allows you to do
and what we the how we have used
functional MRI is to
compare quantitatively the the brain
activation of patients with
various conditions traumatic brain
injury versus those that do not have
injury and we
um I think some of the distinguishing
features with what cognitive FX or
whatever has been described to the court
we have created our own database
aged matched controls
we use a a newer statistical method that
received a U.S patent that allows you to
essentially borrow statistical strength
from the neighbors so it's a cubic
spline interpolation which means the
data is better
sorry for interrupting is this data
available to other researchers who want
to use it and verify it and yes how's
that been done
other people have used it so for example
we shared this with the University of
um at Hershey state in uh
um Penn State sorry in Hershey
uh with with clinical researchers so
it's been used at other facilities
um the the data is
is just a normative database that that
maps for a given area of the brain and
for a given function of the brain what
controls will
exhibit in their functional testing now
we don't try to necessarily draw a
one-to-one conclusion we simply say
in this case we ran this test and this
patient was outside of normal it is a
piece of evidence we're not trying to
conclude that it was necessarily the
traumatic brain injury that caused that
but in this population with
this particular test we have a normal
data set just like you would have a a
blood test a hematocrit or a you know
some other medical test you would create
a normative control and if it falls
outside of that range you would call it
abnormal you might not draw a conclusion
as to why their hematocrit was abnormal
okay I interrupted you sir is there
anything else about your methods that
would verify and provide a foundation or
your use of the fmri in this case
well I think one of the one of the
things that we have done that I think
has pushed the science forward is we
look at the functional areas of
activation of the brain we created maps
of where the for example the frontal
language area or the attentional control
areas earlier attempts have have done
this more on just a standard
geography if you would I've made the
analogy in my deposition that if you
were trying to measure or or to to test
the hypothesis of
of population of of a certain
group of people
they don't always follow exactly the
boundary of the state or the country
that they're in there may be racial
diversity that's concentrated in a
geographic area but not necessarily a
state boundary so what we have done is
to look at
um
functional MRI from a functional Atlas
perspective but it is Data that's
available
certainly people could could take our
our normative controls and compare
against
whatever functional
evaluation they do at their facility we
do not close it
and uh
how did you use
this
fmri technique in this particular case
what makes you
to a degree of reasonable medical
certainty
uh confident that is this is helpful to
understanding Terry sanderson's case
so as I said we run a battery of tests
uh different things that assess higher
cortical function like memory and
problem solving and
um and language processing and so forth
um
in Terry's case all of the tests were
pretty much normal and that's actually
helpful data because you know that
someone is trying or functioning they're
not they're not
it's not a it's not a broken test so to
speak in Terry's case though he did have
fairly significant abnormalities in his
Matrix reasoning test which is
essentially a problem-solving
that requires frontal lobe or higher
cortical function testing
um and so he he did have abnormality he
was
more than two standard deviations below
normal
for his brain activation in that
particular test and so we noted that
that you know this is a piece of data
that suggests
um
a problem with with functional brain
processing
now I'd like to go to relate it to the
specifics of Terry sanderson's case
you understand he had a concussion
there's evidence of that how does that
concussion
inform your work with the fmri so that
you can draw conclusions that might help
the jury understand this
well I mean Terry had a concussion I
don't think there's anyone in the court
that disagrees with that
there are
medical we're looking for objective
evidence that shows whether or not the
concussion
was significant whether it persisted
whether it impaired his ability to do
what he does and there are
um historical pieces of information from
family from Friends there's the medical
record of the time both before and after
and then there's the radiologic Imaging
um
uh in terms of the Imaging that I was
asked to review there were some abnormal
findings on the
chest x-ray there were abnormal findings
on his MRI of the brain and there were
some abnormalities on the functional
scan so it was just one piece of a
multi-factorial picture of Terry
sanderson's concussion
database
uh
who personally or well just uh what's up
queen queen Yang is a researcher at uh
Hershey at
um
at Hershey it's Penn State University
okay I'm sorry
um
I guess you answered that uh what
controls do you employ for your
normative database so we run the exact
same tests on uh patients that have no
known neurologic problems and we We
Gather that data to ask him if they've
had other issues whether it be multiple
sclerosis or
Strokes or whatever so we we
um
it's is a questionnaire and we have
we've employed scans on
people without neurologic
problems
and we've acquired
several hundred patients the current
database that we process is about 50
patients and that's because as
technology evolves as the MRI scanner
has changed coils changed pulse
sequences and so forth change we try to
use a normative control database that
reflects our current actual operating
practice
um so how large is your complete
database
uh we have several hundred patients in
it but but the process the processing
that we do on the current patients is
um you know roughly 50 patients
producible how is it reproducible
well we've done some testing where we uh
test the same person twice on on
different occasions we did about 10
patients where we test and you come back
and retest and see if the data is the
same that's one measure of
reproducibility another
um
another fact that we use is
we take the knowledge that we have as
Physicians and that has been garnered
over you know a century and a half of
neural function from brain surgery from
neurophysiology from Anatomy Etc and
these areas of activation should fit
certain patterns and we see that so it's
it's simply not random activation of the
brain so we have the internal controls
of the symmetry of action in the brain
we have the control of what is of other
data that's
um that that we've studied over over
decades and and we compare that with
with what that normal patient should be
doing
um please describe your for the court
your Publications and other
presentations
regarding your use of the fmri that are
applicable to the Terry Sanderson case
that they provide the foundation for for
your conclusions for Terry Sanderson
so I don't have my CV in front of me but
you may so your honored just for
housekeeping uh how long is this going
to go I think it's a relatively minor
point and our jurors are sitting in the
back rooms I think
it kind of brings us to a year and a
half ago I think we're just about done
Dr Fong's ruling was yesterday
I I don't need a conversation between
Council please address the court
so this
um one of these was a presentation for
the American Society of neuroradiology
at the annual meeting in April 2017 fmri
Atlas for control comparison of six
neurofunctual regions using standardized
neuropsychological tests
um here's another presentation I did at
the radiologic Society of North America
standardized brain function test making
functional MRI standardized fast and
physician friendly
I gave a presentation at Baylor
University I gave one at Penn State in
2016. I gave Grand rounds
to both the University of Pennsylvania
and University of California San Diego
on functional MRI
I spoke at the uh
the 20th Symposium of the neural
radiologic in the world neuroradiology
society in Istanbul Turkey in September
so there's been quite a few
uh presentations about it
two neuroradiologists and other peers
thank you I think that's all I have for
now
okay I just have a couple questions
before Mr Egan so that as I understand
of the normative database consists of
approximately 50.
individuals
yeah so our database actually we have
several hundred but again to to keep the
data
consistent clean we've used the last 50
patients
because we changed MRI scanners here a
couple of years ago so we repeated
aren't already controls okay and there's
some subset of that 50 that has or that
50 has been split into subsets based on
age related controls so you can
dynamically adjust the age range you can
choose the age range do you recall how
many were in the age range that were
compared with the plaintiff's fmri
um
I I don't recall I think we used about
about 50 patients but
many of those would have been younger
patients
and how about has there been any effort
to
quantify statistically the reliability
of your normative database
yes in fact each test uh we print out a
statistical threshold of what the
standard deviation of the normative
controls are and what that patient's
activation were okay and is there an
established rate of error
um
I'm not sure what you mean by that the
standard deviation will tell you what
the probability is that that particular
test
is a false negative or false positive
so if you have two standard deviations
that means the probability is 95 percent
that it falls outside of the normal
range and if it's three standard
deviations it's like 97 okay thank you
Mr vegan
I just have a couple questions you asked
many that I was going to your honor
so I'll just be real brief Dr Gibby uh
good to see you again
um does anyone other than your clinic
use your database
as I said
um Dr Kwing Yang has used it uh okay
anyone other than him
um
yes we set it up at um
at George Washington University
uh a few years ago I had a son attending
residency there I'm I don't know if
they're currently using it but they they
had used it okay and has anyone
any outside researcher
validated your statistical
um analysis that you were just talking
about the standard deviation test
well they've said we we presented this
uh in a peer-reviewed fashion in order
to have the abstracts and so forth
accepted there have been
um I assume Physicians with knowledge
that would that would look at that so we
we publicly given our results yes okay
but has anyone used your database run
your same tests
um you know the various
functional activities you ask people to
do during the scans and then
compared their results with your results
critically analyze those yes I mean that
it when you run the
um when you run the program it
automatically brings up the normative
control group so you can see
the activation of those so they they
would be using those by default you're
not only comparing statistically you're
visually comparing the the activation
patterns of these side by side I think
that's another Advantage here is you're
able to as a neurodeologist compare
visibly how these are activating
okay
um
I think that's all I have your honor
thanks okay thank you any follow-up
over let's say
I don't know how many number of years
you've been informed by your Mr fmri
testing about how many patients
and data points and data points is there
more than one data point per individual
for example the MRI does I think
thousands if not millions of scans
could you explain that for the court
so in order to
quantitate functional activation you
need lots of data and
so each test that we run
has about 1800 images per test and there
will be seven tests at least so you know
we roughly process about 15 000 images
per case
take several hours of processing
so each individual or each let's say 50
patients has three hundreds of thousands
of images in in the patient database yes
and um
you change your machines every ship so
often and you have to recalibrate them
right
I don't know about recalibrate but these
um
we just get better signal to noise so as
technology moves we want to have the
best
data that we can get so a few years ago
when we upgraded our MRI machine we
re-ran all of the statistical controls
uh it's been probably three years ago
therefore
now a larger population of tests for
each individual about 18
000 per individual
that has statistical significance
in your opinion
yeah I mean I I'm I think that the data
speaks for itself you can see just on
the images the quality of the the color
representations of of how the data is
displayed but
um I think it's very good data kind of
like the old black and white TV and now
you get the
uh it's uh We've improved the uh we
decreased The Noise by about a factor of
a square root of 2 1.4 times in the last
few years so the statistical
um and we published on this in fact we
received a patent on this
um we are getting better images than we
did 10 years ago let's just put it that
way
I'll explain the patent
on the scope objection you're on I think
you mentioned the patent the first few
minutes of My overall go ahead
so fmri images are very signal limited
all MRI images are noisy but what you're
looking for is a really subtle change in
the signal intensity because the brain
is using more oxygen
okay so you're looking at a very subtle
change in in signal to noise and the
patent that we did was to do a cubic
spline interpolation of the data which
essentially you look at your neighbors
so if you think about if you saw a
droplet of water in the sky you might
say
oh could that be random or is rain
coming but if you saw a cloud and you
had thousands of droplets of water you
would say it's a rainstorm right and and
so we essentially look at the neighbors
of the of a particular
voxel and and we say is this noise or is
it not and it turns out
if
if the neighbors are activating then
it's more likely that you are also that
yours is not a random noise you know
um so
so by by doing that uh more advanced
statistical analysis we get an a battle
1.4 Improvement in the signal to noise
of the images
thank you thank you
any follow-up Mr Egan there were some
okay thank you Dr Gaby you may step down
thank you
any comments before the court rules
your honor uh
statistics are
dependent I think on numbers and he just
explained the difference there are tens
of thousands per individual of those 50
as far as normative database
and that adds up to a lot and as we know
the higher the
data points the more reliable the
statistical analysis is
Mr Egan
your honor uh just a couple quick points
uh the database as I understand that
involved just 50 patients which seems
like a unreliably small sample size
especially given that it was a lot of
young patients um different than Terry
sanderson's profile it's not generally
used his database and methods and then I
didn't I don't believe I heard anything
that about his particular control
the database that's used to control his
findings being scrutinized I heard it
was used and has been seen by people but
not critically examined by Outsiders
those would be my points okay thank you
forgive me just a minute
okay under rule 702 B which is what the
courts ruling on
the the scientific technical or other
specialized knowledge may serve as the
basis for an expert testimony if there's
a threshold showing
as that the principles or methods are
reliable based on sufficient facts or
data and been reliably applied to the
facts
the this is part of the Court's
gatekeeper function to screen out
unreliable expert testimony
and the court is required to use
rational skepticism in in evaluating
this what the Court's focused on is the
this normative database and what
conclusions that the witness may be
drawing from this normative database
whether it's whether there's been a
threshold showing a reliability and
there's different standards in the
federal court versus Utah they may they
may be the same in this instance but I'm
applying the Utah standard which I
believe that that the witness has
provided a threshold showing of
reliability of of their normative
database they indicated that their
understanding of how to make sure that
the databases is recognized as
scientifically valid that it contains
controls that it's reproducible and then
it's subject to statistical testing and
that this database had all of that while
the the number of patients in that
database seems to be small the
the witness did on a threshold basis
and I'm not commenting on the weight or
how great the evidence is but on a
threshold basis satisfy the court that
uh that there is sufficient
reliability applying those factors the
court also considered
whether it had been tested and or the
subject of peer review analysis or
publication
there's been some publication of the of
the database as well as it being
provided to Independent peers although
it doesn't sound as though anyone is
actually
tested it or written it up it has been
out in this Marketplace of scientific
ideas for many years or several years
anyway that would permit that sort of
analysis
and based on the application of
Statistics to the database as the
witness has described it is the the
reliability of of the findings
are scientifically testable
so I will overrule the objection
anything further before the the uh jury
comes in
okay we're ready for the jury
please
foreign
thank you and good morning members of
the jury
um thank you for your patience this
morning the the lawyers are working hard
to move the case along
um I hope that you weathered the storms
on your way in here today
seem to be coming and going as time went
on but we're ready to proceed Mr Bueller
do you have a witness yes your honor the
plaintiff calls Dr Wendell Gibby
you can take the stand Dr Gibby was
already sworn in by the court before you
arrived
good morning Dr Gibby good morning
could you uh please state your name and
tell us where you come from or where you
were born and where you grew up
probably more than you want to know it's
Wendell Arlen Gibby I was born in Idaho
grew up mostly in Utah and I've lived in
a lot of places around the country
okay starting with high school please
tell us your educational background
so I went to high school at Orem High I
attended Brigham Young University and
graduated in chemistry went to
University of Utah in medical school
from there I did a Diagnostic Radiology
residence well I did an internship in
[Music]
um
it was a rotating internship at UCLA
Harbor General County Hospital Los
Angeles and then a Diagnostic Radiology
residency
at University of Arizona and a
fellowship in
neuro radiology at University of
Pennsylvania I've taught at three
universities for a while I was a young
staff member at University of Utah I
taught the neurorenology and
Interventional Radiology at University
of Arizona for approximately three years
and I'm currently an Adjunct professor
of radiology at University of California
San Diego
uh please explain what uh Radiology is
in layman's terms if you could briefly
Radiology is Imaging
comprises x-rays MRI CT ultrasound those
types of things as well as a growing
practice is the
image guided treatment or Interventional
Radiology so
various treatments of cancer and
degenerative problems with
with image guided therapy is there any
other training you haven't mentioned
that you think the court or the jury
would like to know
um
well I
I founded a software business many years
ago and we've done a lot of Advanced
Imaging so we currently are involved
with an augmented reality guidance
product we've done a number of Advanced
Imaging Technologies over the years we
have about 200 employees and around
about a thousand facilities around the
world
I guess I guess some training
by default
okay describe the types of patients you
treat
so we see a wide spectrum of patients
with imaging
um
as a neuroradiologist I've focused on
the brain and spine
but we see a wide spectrum and in our
clinic in Provo we also read for a half
a dozen other facilities around the
state
okay and what are the types of
patients uh problems do you see for
example brain injury
definitely uh athletic injuries Sports
concussions uh automobile and you know
motor vehicle injury
um
we diagnose and treat a fair number of
people with other neurologic conditions
like multiple sclerosis Strokes
dementia
um
a lot of degenerative problems in
people's spines disc herniations those
types of things
what about rib injuries or injuries to
the Torso do you see many patients like
that
is it within the scope of your training
and Specialty to determine the causation
of traumatic brain injury
yes
yes how so if you could explain that
well
um neuroradiology is the science of
Imaging and diagnosis so we see
virtually any patient that has a
significant head injury will at some
point come through our Imaging with CT
or MRI
I also run an urgent care facility at
our multi-specialty Clinic that I own
I've written textbooks on Imaging I
wrote a 2000 page neurodeology textbook
many years ago that of course it was an
exhaustive review of the literature and
uh
and different cranial uh problems so I
think I'm qualified to discuss brain
injury what about rib injuries are you
qualified to
discuss those and how so
well you know I also am involved with
General Radiology we read lots of plain
x-rays when I was at Utah Valley
Hospital I was there for about 15 years
I was chairman of the department for a
couple of years
we had a we had a large uh population of
trauma patients coming in it was a
tertiary referral center uh also what I
was at University of Utah and the
University of Arizona we had large
populations of trauma patients coming in
and
you know that body injury and rip trauma
is a is a common
problem in in trauma patients it's it's
a common process so it's any general
audiologist should be qualified to
reader rib fracture
I just if she could give us a really
rough estimate uh how many patients have
you seen over your career and maybe
approximately how many scans have you
seen radiological scans
um tens of thousands
I I
a lot so
typically a radiologist will see
roughly a hundred patients a day
so over a
you know
250 day year and a 30-year career you
could do the math but we see lots of
images
if you could explain for the jury uh
what is a closed head injury or closed
head brain injury
uh it's trauma that involves the
inside or the the cranial contents but
doesn't necessarily break the skull or
lacerate the skull so
typically some type of deceleration
injury the human Cranium of course is a
marvelous
organ we do incredible things as humans
um
but one of the things that was not built
or designed for is rapid deceleration
and so we see lots of head injuries in
in sports in motor vehicular trauma
and so the brain is bathed in this
bath of CSF fluid that acts as a shock
absorber but if it if the skull stops
quickly and the brain doesn't stop it
will
strike or Bounce Around inside the skull
and it can create shock waves of energy
that will disrupt fiber Connections in
the brain
so as a close to head brain injury the
same as a traumatic brain injury or TBI
yes and explain what a mtbi is
and how it compares to other tbis
well
um
they're different gradations of TBI so
dramatic brain injury can be
um
you know everything from a person is
comatose and decerebrate and
non-functional to transient uh you know
loss of consciousness
um
we see lots of uh in repeated traumatic
brain injury where even even short
duration injuries can have fairly
profound sequela that's that's been
um a notable process in the news in the
last few years with the NFL and other
sports programs but uh
yeah it's it's just an issue of
gradation
okay
and uh
just to explain for us because it's been
used
post-concussion symptoms
explain what those are
well for the human brain to work there's
a lot of inter connectedness that has to
happen and the the simple things that we
would do like move our arm or breathe or
you know
um
it doesn't take a lot of brain function
but some of the higher cortical
functions that we have in terms of
emotional control
in terms of
executive functioning problem solving
multitasking I mean you think of the the
billions of interconnections that have
to happen in order for the brain to to
function correctly
and
so
unlike say if you were to pluck out a
part of the brain the the problems with
a um
with a concussion tend to be
more generalized they they tend to
affect systems so people often exhibit
memory challenges memory requires a lot
of interplay of the brain they will have
depression so emotional ability people
will find that they can't control their
anger as well the frontal lobes are
vital for creating
you know the the normal personal
relationships and and control of how we
act to people and if those areas get
damaged
uh people don't have the same ability to
control their emotions
um oftentimes it will reflect in
sleeplessness so difficulty with
sleeping
um
so there's you know there's a there's a
wide variety of symptoms that people
will have after a concussion and it can
be somewhat variable in terms of how
they resolve or whether they resolve at
all
how many people suffering a concussion
in your experience with your training
completely recover
well the vast majority I mean I think I
saw a statistic a few years back in
Collegiate sports or something like 300
000 concussions a year
so there's a lot of people that Bang
into each other and they will sustain
brief loss of consciousness and you know
ring their Bells so to speak
so the vast majority of people get
better after a concussion
but what about those who don't uh how
many are you know approximately are
um
I think that again is a is a factor
related to age underlying problems
so
a 20 year old is more likely to recover
from a concussion than an 80 year old
someone who has a single concussion is
more likely to to recover than someone
who has repeated injuries
someone who has an underlying brain
problem
um and their their brain is you know
currently functioning well but this can
tip them over to create
uh dysfunction
so I don't know what that statistic is
uh and I'm I think it's probably the
wrong question because
what you really should ask is has it
happened and what evidence is that it
persists you know that because once if
it occurs it's it's a hundred percent
probability it's a hundred percent
probability that that person has a
concussion
symptoms
and what are those
symptoms that typically persist let's
say in someone like Terry Sanderson who
was 69 at the time of this crash
yeah so so Terry actually if you if you
read his record which is fairly
extensive and the depositions of people
that uh had known Terry very well his
partner
his children his friends
um
Terry had been a very high functioning
high energy person
he was
every day doing lots of things meetup
groups skiing wine tasting
and volunteering for various
organizations and so forth but
after his accident he
deteriorated abruptly and many of the
activities that he used to do he stopped
doing like dancing
for the most part his skiing activities
his personal interactions with his
children and his grandchildren suffered
he had trouble
multitasking he normally could you know
handle multiple projects at once but he
would have to sit there and focus very
hard on on one task he would go to Home
Depot for example and forget why he was
there what what you know what was he
supposed to get there and and one
occasion on the record he describes
having to call the police to come and
pick him up because he's lost his car
when when he was hiking something that
hadn't happened to him before
he his girlfriend
expressed this change where he had this
emotional liability he would get angry
he would
be very emotional about things which was
atypical for Terry
um
so
he also experienced a worsening of his
depression and
so those are very typical Hallmarks of
someone who has had a traumatic brain
injury
someone who has persistent
post-concussive symptoms that last
longer than a let's say a year and a
half
are those uh what what does that mean
for someone like Terry in the general
population
well I I think that
um you know in Terry's case he was a
it been a physician an optometrist he
was
a very active guy he was well respected
by his family had a close relationship
with his daughters
um and um
but I think he lost some of that
connectedness is he would be angry with
his grandchildren for example and the
record it talks about an incident where
he's you know yelling at his
granddaughter for closing a door or
something
just difficulty maintaining friendships
difficulty
um
with the relationships that he had the
the partner that he was with they split
they
um
you know I I think that
the ability to function at a high level
was lost for Terry it required him he
could function he still functions and he
was a bright guy to begin with so
certainly capable of doing most things
but many of the things that gave him
pleasure in life and
many of those friendships and
relationships seem to have been abruptly
diminished by this injury
you mentioned the record please tell the
jury some of the things that you
reviewed in this case
so I reviewed
um of course
did you meet with uh examine or meet
with doctors or Terry Sanderson I did
meet with Terry
examined him briefly we did some
Advanced Imaging of his brain both
anatomic Imaging
saw some findings that were consistent
with normal pressure hydrocephalus we
did CSF flow imaging and we also did
some functional brain Imaging so that
was the primary reason for meeting Terry
but I did get a chance to talk to him
and spend about a half an hour with him
um I also reviewed all of the Imaging
because that's what I am as a
radiologist
that
included images that were done shortly
after the accident a CT scan
um the day following his injury rib
X-rays and chest x-rays that were
performed the day after his injury
um follow-up
MRI images of his brain of his thoracic
spine Etc that were done at a facility
called cognitive FX and then the images
of course that we performed several
years later and and for the medical
record I reviewed
notes from the Veterans Hospital
um
literally hundreds of pages of various
uh medical records the accident report
from Deer Valley uh you know the ski
report incident
um
I reviewed the depositions of his
children to two of his daughters and his
partner and his friend Craig Ramon and
uh
I reviewed the uh testimony of other
expert witnesses that were provided so a
lot of data
did you also review the defenses
expert reports I did
I'll just mention them briefly just to
refresh your memory there's a galit
Ashkenazi
she's a neuropsychologist do you
remember reviewing hers I do
Angela she another
neuropsychologist is Angela eastvold
yes and then um
these are the next three are MD's Robert
Hesh Stephen actually and Carl Black you
reviewed those too yes
I'm just it's going to be I don't know
if you can see the screen and if it's
okay with the judge can he step out to
look at it sure
just want to make sure I pick up the
audio is all
I don't think there's going to be audio
here oops that's my screen saver
daughter and wife
well I don't wanna
just do you have to exhibit book
Mr Beeler before you show oh I'm sorry
you just let us know yeah oh yeah I'm
going to show uh uh plaintiff's exhibits
um sorry
I'm gonna show plaintiff's exhibit three
first and then the next ones will be
those uh one
they're the same ones you showed
plaintiff's tree has already been
received okay
so first I'm going to show
well I'm going to show
yeah I'll show plaintiff's exhibit three
okay this is uh
plaintiff's exhibit three
and it's already been admitted
you can see
uh
okay
so you see it's the date of the incident
Dr Gibby do you see that I do okay and
it was uh timing of the incident is 11
55 a.m just before noon
um
the the name of the student is deleted
but I'll represent that it's uh Gwyneth
Paltrow we have that elsewhere
um skier Wright bandana slight pitch
before flat on top
um
then I'm going to show you the um
was not a student so but that's what was
written on the report I think we have
that elsewhere it was deleted I think
for privacy purposes when it was a child
I'm quite sure I think it was done to
protect the privacy and that's why it
was deleted here but it's not the child
this is there were probably four
children here but I'll uh what the main
thing I wanted to show is uh
um
that uh
the person filling out this report
Eric Christensen says I didn't see it
but heard of her screen
you've reviewed this report correct Dr
Gibby go ahead
then but down below I'm going to just go
down to the bottom
and here it says instructor name Eric
Christensen
then I'm going to go up here and other
employees guess
it mentions the other instructor Carrie
Oaks
and in addition to saying
um
I didn't see it he also indicates down
here did you witness the incident no
he said I saw the immediate aftermath
um
and uh
then it says uh
do you see where it says both were in
discomfort
I do and during lunch she talked of
being stiff and sore
uh I believe that would reference the
the student there which I think we'll be
able to show later that Gwyneth
Paltrow's name was there because this
was the one provided to the plaintiff
when he asked for a record of what
happened
um
so uh
uh does does this uh idea that both were
in discomfort does that inform you that
uh
there may have been a traumatic event
after this ski Collision that caused
injury
go ahead
well I don't think it's in question that
there was a collision and oops two
individuals were
involved in a collision on the ski slope
so I I'm not sure what
I mean yes they both they both were
injured
uh I just want to quickly go through
these but I'll try to be fast
um
there we go come on
now this is plaintiff's exhibit one I
moved to admit plaintiff's exhibit one
at the incident report of the ski
patroller Whitney Smith we can take it
off oh sorry
any objection no no okay plaintiff's
exhibit one is received
okay
um
we can see this is planus exhibit one
again it's the same date you see that
right
I do and it says injured person Terry
Sanderson
and then
uh location bandana
Collision yes
with unknown other party not present
description of the skier is Advanced
intermediate
and uh
you know I apologize to interrupt but
I'm wondering if there's a question okay
instead of just reading through the
record did this record inform you to as
a basis of your opinions
I did review this record yes okay
to this one
well I'm going to just briefly go back
to this
this is a page two
of the record and see if it pops up
again there it goes
this is page two of exhibit one
and it says uh
what did you do
assessment mild disorientation and rib
pain right side
you see that
did this uh inform your opinions yes and
transport via toboggan to EFA which I
understand is Empire first aid
reassessment disorientation lessened
how does disorientate or what does
disorientation mean to you
after a ski Collision like this
uh it's symptoms of a head injury
three I'd like to know
um
okay I'm going to go back to page one
um I forgot to emphasize this uh
uh do you see where it says was hit from
behind
yes that's the injured's description of
the incident
I'm going to go to page three
and you'll note the date at the bottom
of page three it wasn't February 26
2016. it was three weeks later March 18
2016.
so the author of this report Whitney
Smith wrote A supplement do you see that
I do okay
and so she didn't write this the first
time
and she didn't have the name of the
other party
on the report but she did have this
written
I
um
let's see I can't read it myself let's
see what does that word oh I recall
because she's recalling three weeks
later that upon arriving on the scene on
bandana at the bridge I found patient
Terry Sanderson
standing on the right
there was uh
on the right side of the run in in his
skis the mountain hosts that radio
Patrol was above doing traffic control a
friend of Terry's was also present a
large man Blue Jacket black pants dark
hair hereby referred to as large male
friend
I'll represent to you that that large
male friend testified yesterday his name
is Craig Ramon
you read this part of the report too
correct I have
Terry said that he was uncertain what
happened
large male friend told Terry that a
woman had struck him from behind
knocking him down
large male friend stated he believed the
woman had been Gwyneth Paltrow
does that inform your opinions about
what happened in the ski crash
yes
okay and it looks like uh
I asked Whitney Smith writes three weeks
later I asked if anyone had spoken to
the woman large male friend said he had
asked her if she was all right
he said she had told him she was fine
and skied away
during that this is three weeks later so
um
during assessment transport and time at
the first aid large male friend
continued to say that the woman involved
in the Collision was Gwyneth Paltrow
um and then it goes on to describe at
Empire first aid we were met by three
others from Terry Skeen group a blonde
woman a man and Debbie I recall a large
male friend
reiterating to the group his
identification of the woman to have been
Gwyneth Paltrow
Debbie left to retrieve the car from
snow park and the other three friends
left a while later to continue skiing
stayed with I stayed in monitored Terry
until Debbie arrived with a car and took
him to the clinic
then she writes at the bottom I believe
the other party lmf was Craig that's uh
do you understand that to be Craig Ramon
correct thank you for going through this
uh with me because uh I want to uh
just set the foundation for what
happened
and uh what informs your opinions
you know I'm going to show you a
progress note uh sorry your honor I'd
like to uh move to admit plaintiff's
exhibit four
rejection
no plaintiff's exhibit four is received
this is a progress note data this date
of the Collision February 26 2016.
it's not clear what time whether that's
a 24-hour clock or not
um
and it's by this Michael McMahon he may
or may not appear and provide testimony
but this is what he wrote about this on
that date uh Vital Signs weighed 177
pounds
and then uh
said a patient collided with another
skier at approximately 1300 today this
is why the 915 is not clear whether that
is a
that may not be a time that corresponds
to any real time it could be a clock
that's not set or something but at 1300
today that would be 1 pm correct
yeah anyway it states he lost
Consciousness and ski patrol responded
patient was helmeted
and then it says complains mild headache
and pain when taking a deep breath what
does that indicate to you Dr Gibby
well he was evaluated by a physician
assistant at an InstaCare
um
it it's clear that he had
some chest symptoms with his he was
having trouble breathing having pain
with with deep breaths and that he had
some period of loss of consciousness
which was
reported by the provider it sounded like
that
the provider suggested a CT scan but
Terry declined it
I think that there was enough certainly
enough uh injury to warrant
concern for a CT scan
the bottoman says after brief discussion
to determine stability patient was
referred to the emergency room by
private vehicle for CT scan and further
evaluation
does that support the opinion that Terry
suffered a concussion that day February
26 2016. it does and he ultimately had a
CT scan and images of his of his broken
ribs
um
I I apologize for making you go through
all these simple records but they're
important
um
you're on a uh I moved to admit
plaintiff's exhibit five
no okay plaintiff's exhibit five is
received
so this is dated February 27 the day
after the Collision
it's an emergency department
I'll represent that it's the Veterans
Hospital
sometimes I think it's down here
somewhere
yeah printed at George E Whalen
Veterans Administration Medical Center
in Salt Lake City
and uh
anyway it's a
multi-page document
I'm not going it also has other dates
but I'm going to focus just on that date
and uh
says ski accident yesterday with
positive loc what is loc loss of
consciousness
and it states slight h a headache
and today being more irritable
and complains of right lateral rib pain
that is worse with inspiration denies
neck pain did that inform your opinions
yes
before we get on to the rib rib x-rays
they'll come later tell us what your
opinions about the concussion
that the plane of selege happened on
February 26 2016. did Terry suffer one
yes
I don't think there's any
dispute among providers the people that
were present
uh Terry's own testimony
um
he had a loss of consciousness he had a
significant head injury he struck the
ground and uh even though he was
helmeted he was unconscious for a period
of time it's been described variably in
the record from two minutes to 40
minutes but
seemed like it was you know several
minutes duration
and what does LLC mean with regard to a
concussion
uh it it is one of the predictive
markers of some of a concussion that's
more serious
so loss of consciousness means that the
person is not aware or not not
functioning in their surroundings
now you've read the report or the
testimony of Craig Ramon the witness at
the Collision site correct
I have read his deposition
okay he testified yesterday
you know represent that I don't think it
was in conflict with his deposition but
um
what opinions do you have about the
cause of this TB uh concussion that
Terry suffered that day February 26th
well uh
I mean the the cause of the concussion
was a collision he
he was
uh I don't think there's any question
that Collision occurred both
Witnesses from uh the ski school
and uh Terry and Terry's friends
describe a significant Collision there's
an arguing about who caused what but
that's something to be discussed later
but there was a collision
um in my opinion the Collision involved
Terry at some point striking a hard
enough object to break his ribs and to
create a a brain injury and
I think that the only object there that
would have that could have provide
sufficient Force for that would be
either a direct
you know
helmet to the head which did not occur
or striking the ground and so it's my
opinion the hair that Terry's concussion
was caused by him
striking the ground and hitting his head
would striking the force of striking the
ground I'm going to skip ahead to the
rib injury would it striking the
ground increase if he had someone on his
back
well I think that the force of injury
and just falling over
would not be the same Force as if you
have
someone
striking you and and knocking you over
if you have the combined mass of two
people that would also increase the
force on that so
yeah I think that the combination of
those things
probably
increased his his
likelihood for injury
would Terry sanderson's uh
rib injuries also inform you about how
severe the impact was
yeah so on his chest x-ray which I'm not
sure if you've shown the jury but and I
I did bring a computer so I can bring
those up if you would like but he had
four displaced rib fractures so they
were on the lateral side on his right
side
um and
[Music]
um
Terry was 69 at the time male had
very normal looking bone density so
certainly not
elderly elderly or osteoporotic
and in order to break since we Snap Four
ribs would require a substantial amount
of force
okay your honor I'd like to admit
plano's exhibit 30 the chest x-rays
plaintiff's exhibit 30 is received
Dr Gibby are these chess x-rays that you
reviewed
uh yes but these are really low
resolution for copies so I'm not sure
what you're trying to show here
mostly to remind you that these are the
chest x-rays you reviewed at one time
okay and uh
we understand x-ray experts like
yourself Radiologists like to have
the pure images but this is mostly to
refresh your memory of what you reviewed
yeah but you cropped off where the
fractures are located on the right side
there are they do you see them there no
okay I think we might have a better
version of that but we'll deal with that
later can we plug his computer in I can
I can plug my computer in let you see it
directly yeah
okay
have a short recess
Mr Bueller your voice is a little quiet
at times maybe you could just direct
this a little closer to you
is that little portable thing working
yesterday yes it was
yeah should I use that yeah your choice
either
all right thank you
all right
thank you
hmm
say Bridget judgment problems with the
computer
that is the basis for the report that he
had reviewed as deposition it's exhibit
and then also 31.
which is a better blow up of the rivet
x-rays the one I had was uh
objection to the rape image which is 31
but we definitely object to 32 which is
that 2009 MRI
you object to him
to Dr Gibby but how about as an exhibit
the objective of being entered as an
exhibit we object to Dr Gibby on bring
opinions about it and he did not write
his deposition but how about just the
exhibit oh just admitting it
um
well we don't want him talking about it
yeah I think I think this is actually
from us your Hunter so we would not
objective today latest exhibits 31 and
32 I received as to whether the witness
can testify regarding 32 do you have do
you have a record of him I mean can this
witness I did can you can you have this
witness identify whether he reviewed it
prior to his deposition
could Council please approach as soon as
the jury comes in
thank you
foreign
thank you for your patience
Dr Gibby I have a better photograph or
version of the chest x-ray I'd just like
to
show that you to you briefly so we can
see it this is a plaintiff's exhibit 31.
it has been received okay
I have
what is uh the importance of this to
your opinions Dr Gibby
uh this was an x-ray taken the day after
his incident
um
showing it's a series of images of his
ribs
and I think the importance of this is
documenting the trauma that he sustained
and and I described that to the jury yes
please
why is it important we lost the image oh
yeah I'm sorry I'll put it back up I
thought we were done
you make
fractures
yeah would you like the pointer the
laser
the microphone there for you
I can speak loudly that helps
okay we can hear you
so this
these white bands are the ribs which are
right on an X-ray because they are
against them and you can see here where
the rib is this recipe there's a
fracture here
there's one here
there's one
here
four fractured ribs along the lateral
side of his right chest and it's over a
substantial area uh
seven or eight inches to cross through
the chest but I just wanted you to see
that these are they're not so in these
directions
so uh
Dr Gibby
the
concussion and the broken ribs
what opinions do you draw about
uh
the extent of Terry sanderson's injuries
well I don't think it was you know just
a minor bump he had enough Force to
knock him unconscious uh enough Force to
have persisting cranial symptoms that
are documented in the record and enough
Force to break four of the ribs on the
right side of his chest
and
um
that along with the deceleration of uh
striking the ground
I think was I mean I think that the rib
fractures certainly corroborate
that there was enough Force to cause a
head injury
and of course he was complaining of the
rib pain immediately after the accident
and subsequently had this evaluated by
the
InstaCare and then I think he went to
the veterans hospital probably because
he was a vet and had the ability to get
free care there
the next day
okay
um
well I think you answered my next
question
what injuries did this crash cause are
there is there anything else that you
can comment on that formula or that are
the basis of your opinion or give the
jury your opinion
um
well I think those are the ones that are
described in the record he does have
some abnormalities on his spine
uh both in in the cervical area
but I don't think those have been
addressed in
uh by the patient or in in the court as
as part of this process so the two
primary complaints he had were the chest
injury which
uh healed over a period of months rip
fractures can be very very painful uh
it's
in in some cases
um they will go in and plate the ribs
back together in order to reduce the
risk of lung cancer and to help people
heal quicker we also do some pain
management techniques with this where we
will inject
um
Cortisone and numbing medicine around
the broken ribs but as you can imagine
every time someone takes a breath
that fracture is moving
um unlike say a long bone you can't
really cast the chest you can't
immobilize it so it does take a period
of time for these to heal and and again
it makes it difficult to breathe as a
result of them
um
do the rib fractures
indicate that Dr Sanderson or Terry
Sanderson was hit from the rear and from
the side
and why
so I think that's you know one of the
the really the core questions of this
case
it doesn't seem to be any dispute that
there was a collision
um it does uh it doesn't seem to be any
dispute that there were injuries Dr
Sanderson experienced enough trauma to
break ribs and cause a concussion
then the question is was this something
that
he caused or the defendant caused and
based upon my analysis of the x-rays and
the reports from witness the witness
Craig who was there I think it's very
unlikely that this would have been
caused
by Terry running into
Gwyneth Paltrow first of all when you're
skiing your knees would be bent your
arms would
maybe we should approach for this one
sure
foreign
uh Dr Gibby what's your opinion as to
how this crash these injuries were
caused
I think based on the uh the stated
testimony of
of the defendant of Craig Ramon who was
the only eyewitness and based upon the
pattern of injuries that are present
here
um
what I believe happened is that he was
struck from the left side
and that forced him into the ground
it's it's also been the testimony here
that Miss Paltrow was on top of him at
some point so the combined weight of the
two individuals slamming into the ground
caused the fracture and the head injury
and I don't think it would be plausible
that if he were running into her that he
would have broken the ribs on the side
of his chest
he likely would have had his arms
extended he would have protected himself
he would have had knees arms Etc in
front of his chest and so he might have
had other injuries he could have broken
leg or an arm or a wrist or something
like that but but in terms of a frontal
collision had he run into Miss Paul's I
don't think he would have had these
types of injuries and
um and I also think you know just given
the differential and mass of the people
involved I I think uh she would have
broken his fall so to speak reduced his
his Collision velocity and and the
impact and probably if had he been the
person running into her I don't think he
would have sustained these types of
injuries
thank you
does your expertise allow you to make
these conclusions like you do
yes
now I'd like to talk about the
head injury again we went through the
ribs we'll go back and forth
you've examined Terry Sanderson and it
was about five years after the crash
correct
what can you tell the jury about
how persistent his injuries are and
whether they're they are permanent
I think the record is fairly uh replete
with examples of where Terry has
continued to suffer from
uh some some neurologic deficits both in
his ability to focus his ability to
perform tasks
his memory
and especially his interpersonal
relationships emotional ability and
anger management and some of those
things which Terry had not had those
issues prior to the accident so I do
think his
his symptoms have been uh persistent
there is some effort evidence in the
record from his daughter that some of
these things had gotten a bit better
that he had improved but he wasn't back
to normal
will he ever get back to normal and why
you know I I I don't know
um the human brain has some plasticity
to it but as we get older our ability to
reform neural connections and to
improve diminishes substantially with
time
and
typically if a person has not
regained that function or lost capacity
within about 12 to 18 months they're
probably not going to get it back
why wasn't Miss Paltrow hurt
significantly in this Collision
well I I don't know that I have an
answer to that you know Miss Paltrow
first of all the record suggest that she
was heard she was stiff and sore after
the accident at lunch
uh at least that's what the ski
instructor reported
um
she's much younger than Terry and
therefore probably more capable of
that type of collision but
um
I I I don't want to speculate I mean she
could have been injured yes
I'd like to uh
refer you to the defense experts you
reviewed their reports correct I didn't
and
why don't we start with the
the medical doctors
doctors uh
Gibby excuse me doctors black
Edgley and Hesh
um
how do you differ or what what is your
response to their opinions in this case
well you'd probably have to refresh my
memory and some of their opinions
because that's a fairly blanket
statement but I I can recall at least
some of the opinions of Dr Black he had
Refuge reviewed the Imaging and
suggested that there were evidence of
multi infarct white matter disease and
there was atrophy of the brain I don't
think in Terry's case there's much
atrophy his cortical diary the the
cortex itself is still very well
preserved for his age what he has is
dilatation of his ventricles so at least
the inner part of the brain looks
the the fluid pathways are dilated but I
don't think he has significant brain
atrophy as you might see in someone with
Dementia or multiple Strokes or a
long-standing uh
so in that respect I would disagree with
Dr Black I do I do think that Dr Black
discussed the um
the diagnosis of normal pressure
hydrocephalus and I'd like to just say
that is a clinical diagnosis and Terry
Sanders did not have any of the
clinical symptoms associated with
normal pressure hydrocephalus he had
radiologic findings of dilated
ventricles but he had not progressed he
had a compensated hydrocephalus
essentially
but many people had dilated ventricles
and they do just fine
what
um what he clearly did not have were the
classic symptoms of normal pressure
hydrocephalus such as
problems with his gate Ataxia for
example if someone is a toxic they're
probably not going to be skiing
he did not have symptoms of dementia he
was a very bright active engaged person
he did not have difficulty with urinary
incontinence or you know urinary
problems so the typical symptoms of
normal pressure hydrocephalus which is
usually diagnosed later
I think it was just Serendipity that
these images found the
these dilated ventricles but in Terry's
case I don't think they were causing
symptoms and I don't think they're the
primary cause of his current symptoms
and it and by the way the ventricular
dilatation had been present for at least
a decade they were seen on a CT scan at
the Veterans Hospital a decade earlier
and they had been stable for a long
period of time
can you talk about NPH being a risk
factor for uh persistent post-concussive
symptoms
well I think in this case you know some
of the risk factors for
having persistent
problems with concussion one of the risk
factors is if you've had repeated trauma
we know that from football players and
other athletes
another risk factor is age as you get
older your brain has a harder time
adjusting
but I think in Terry's case he had this
condition where his his fluid spaces
these the lateral and third ventricles
were dilated and as a result the fibers
that connect the halves of the brain
together are stretched over this
structure water is not a very
compressible substance if you
put a shock wave into water like you
know you drop a depth charge in a
submarine that force is violently
transmitted to the submarine and
in the case of Terry he had this these
fluid spaces that were enlarged in the
inner inside of his brain and
his
fiber connections his white matter was
already somewhat stretched it was
already
you know at risk and that shock or that
rapid deceleration injury
um
likely was exacerbated by the
presence of this underlying condition
so are the problems Terry's experiencing
now with
is persistent concussive symptoms
how was that uh or was that caused by
pre-existing conditions or by this
concussion and why
well I don't think it's I mean in terms
of trying to figure out causation you
have to look at
um
what happened before and what happened
after beef immediately before the event
Terry was in a stable committed
relationship with a with a person
he had a great relationship with his
daughters and his grandchildren he had
many friends he was very sociable
by all accounts a gregarious sort of
outgoing person
this event happens and he has a very
abrupt change of personality of his
functioning and so I don't think you can
claim that the slow well actually very
stable you know over the decade previous
with his normal pressure hydrocephalus
whatever that was did not cause his
abrupt change in symptoms post-accident
now we all age we all get symptoms over
time and
you know
could the normal pressure hydrocephalus
affect him at some point in his life
absolutely
but so could other other problems
related to aging
okay uh
Dr Stephen Edgley medical doctor
indicates in his report that
uh none of plaintiff's medical records
support his claims that per perceive
symptoms of cognitive decline are
related to the ski Collision how do you
respond to the defense's expert on that
well obviously the defense expert has a
paid to give a certain storyline the I
think the record is very clear that he
had changes in his behavior in his
interpersonal relationships and uh in
his functioning so I'm not sure how this
doctor could claim that there were no
symptoms related to the accident
um
so yeah I I think I think that's wishful
thinking
uh Dr Robert Hesh spelled h-o-e-s-c-h
indicates that Terry's uh neurological
persisting neurological conditions or
symptoms
that he reports since the ski crash
are likely attributable to pre-existing
health conditions
how do you respond to Dr Hesh
well again
um he wasn't suffering from those
pre-existing health conditions before
the accident
there are some things in the medical
record he had a an embolic event to his
right eye so he lost most of the vision
in
it so he did have some visual changes he
had some age-related hearing loss which
in the medical record was described as
mild he was using hearing aids not
uncommon at that age
he had had a history of high blood
pressure although
it had been well controlled he was on
blood pressure medication I think that
the Imaging that I did and that others
have done on his brain over the last
decade have not shown the sequelae of
the uh you know that somehow
hypertension was causing
brain problems he does not have multiple
tiny white matter infarcts in the
location that you typically see with
hypertensive disease he has some white
matter disease around the corpus
callosum where these stretched
ventricles are but hypertensive white
matter disease usually occurs where
there are little small in vessels kind
of at the zones where the there isn't
great blood supply to the white matter
so deep white matter places like the
thalamual striated arteries and the
basal ganglia the pons deep brain
structures and he has none of that he
has no little infarcts in those in those
areas that are typical for hypertensive
related
brain injury or white matter disease he
has no cortical infarcts that would be
related to previous Strokes
you know he had a few other conditions
he had a laminectomy on his back which I
think is completely unrelated he had had
some arthritis and a finger and a thumb
so yeah he Terry Sanders had some
medical issues and medical complaints
there's no question about it but I don't
think we can blame
his current
medical conditions on
just pre-existing conditions
so a neuropsychologist
Angela eastvold also has opinions about
Terry
she confirms that he had a mild
concussion but then goes on to say
that the course and evolution of his
self-reported symptoms
are inconsistent with
the known trajectory of concussive
related symptoms
what is your response to Dr eastvold
well I agree with her that Terry had a
concussion I think we can agree that
much
um
the normal trajectory of concussive
um of concussive patients is it is
typically to recover so yes and that in
that regard he did not follow the normal
trajectory but
this is not a normal case this is a case
that he has continued to suffer and
he had an Abrupt change in his
activities and in his functioning so
um
you know I guess people can disagree
politely
um
do you think that uh
any of Terry's previous pre-existing
conditions
NPH or sore finger or
occasional depression
did that contribute to why he has these
long-stand or did that cause his
long-standing problems that are evident
now
but I think you make a point there I
mean he had been treated in the past for
depression so he was on medication for
that
depression is a pretty common diagnosis
in modern society
but it seems that his condition worsened
following this event so yes I think the
Depression was a pre-existent condition
that that might be conflated with some
of his current symptoms but certainly
not all of those not all of his symptoms
oh well
again what is the primary cause of his
current
PCS persistent concussive symptoms or
is it the ski crash versus these other
causes
well the abrupt change in his
functioning in his behavior and in his
um
his ability to interact with people
um was not something brought on by his
pre-existing conditions he had had those
for many many years and it functioned
well it was stable and so his NPH had
been a stable for a decade and I I'm not
even sure I should call it mph he had
these dilated ventricles he did not have
a clinical diagnosis of MBA
um he he he
was well managed with these other issues
his hypertension was controlled he
wasn't having Strokes
so
yeah I don't I don't see that we can
pin his current problems on his
on the pre-existing issues
you also used an or conducted an fmri on
Terry Sanderson can you explain what
that was
we did so fmri is a is a test where we
look at the brain while the patient is
doing certain tasks so it's
uh so imaging has evolved over time in
the old old days we just took x-rays and
you could couldn't even see inside the
brain and then we started injecting air
into the ventricles to see if there was
a shift and then CAT scans came along
and
but as as medicine has evolved we've
been able to image with much greater
sensitivity and specificity so it's not
surprising that his CT scan which was
taken the day after his accident was
negative he didn't show any evidence of
acute trauma at that time
his MRI scans showed some small white
matter lesions around the corpus
callosum which may have been related to
some stretching injury or some type of
injury at the time of the accident
but lots of people get white matter
disease as you get older that's sort of
like wrinkles
um
We performed a functional MRI where we
had him do actual
tests in the scanner so solving puzzles
having him do memory tests doing
um
you know spatial recognition and and
things that require higher cortical
function and we we subjected Terry to
seven different functional MRI tests and
of those seven one was abnormal and that
was The Matrix reasoning test and he was
below two standard deviations compared
to our normative controls on that test
and that is essentially the major
reasoning is a is a puzzle solving uh
test where you're using lots of frontal
lobe activity as well as your occipital
areas that are involved with visualizing
images and uh spatial recognition Etc
and those are they're frontal and
occipital areas are two common places
that that can be injured in a traumatic
deceleration process so of the I think
the good news is that most of his
Imaging looked normal or within normal
limits within the yardstick we have of
the of the best functional Imaging today
um I I think that the value of
functional Imaging is that we can
actually watch patients while they are
doing
complex tasks
uh something like a an anatomic scan of
the brain people can have normal MRIs of
their brain but be very abnormal they're
going to have schizophrenia or Autism or
severe depression or
bipolar disorder or you know all kinds
of issues and the Brain will look normal
but it doesn't function normally so this
is an attempt to move that boundary of
of uh investigation of brain and using
MRI in a functional manner to assess if
he could perform these complex
operations and how he performed those
compared to normative controls and he
did have an abnormal
functional test on his Matrix reasoning
it's been said test uh Terry Sanderson
has high test scores in other areas by
neurologists neuropsychologists medical
doctors
does that mean he
he doesn't have a brain injury and why
well
lots of people there's a variability in
the population in terms of their
function
um
Terry is a very bright individual very
capable and um
but that doesn't mean that you know
he doesn't sustain an injury and move
from
really bright really capable to just you
know within the average or within normal
uh average so
I I think that the best test and we've
we've had doctors provide evidence about
you know brain scans we've had
neurologists testify neuropsychologists
but really the best test that we have
for humans is how do they perform in a
complex world
you think about it just
how you you drove here
to Park City on a snowy morning that
requires a lot more
processing power than you know even the
best computers that can do today
um so I think that the best the best
test the best challenge of Terry
Sanderson is how how is he doing how is
he functioning in life and I think there
are a number of areas where he has had a
fall off in his abilities
one of his treaters recommended that
after this ski crash
after about 18 months that he tried to
do as many activities he did before such
as travel
or
be active like he was as much as he can
but maybe travel with a partner so he
wouldn't get lost
what is your opinion on those kinds of
recommendations
I mean I think that
many people have
injuries and they they try to overcome
them through various activities I think
probably the worst thing that he could
do is to
sit at home and be depressed and not and
not have those interactions so yes I
mean Terry was a self-described person
who did a lot of travel before and I'm
sure he didn't travel afterwards but I
don't think that that is evidence that
he is somehow
you know unimpaired that he's that he
hasn't had any any symptoms related to
this injury did you see any any evidence
of malingering or faking or he was
trying to exaggerate his injuries
uh no I I didn't
um on the functional MRI I think is
difficult to fake because you have it's
the scanner is actually washing your
brain as you process this data and you'd
have to be pretty
pretty smart to try to fake if you would
the the MRI scanner in terms of how the
blood is flowing and where the brain is
activating uh usually when we see
someone who is faking or not trying then
many of the tests are screwed up you
know they're just
it doesn't make sense but
all of his tests except one were within
normal range and I think he certainly
was drawing
we didn't mention I don't think in
detail at least one neuropsychologist
for the
galit Ashkenazi
she seems to think that following the
incident
Terry suffered from exacerbation of
anxiety and depression
which returned to Baseline in about five
months but there's no evidence of any
permanent mental Health changes
how would you respond to Dr oskanasis
I'm not sure what data she used I think
that
again the record is fairly
replete with uh
there's lots of evidence in here and in
fact his former
partner girlfriend that he had during
the time of the injury
they separate I don't think she has any
any
um
ulterior motive I mean at this point
they're not together why would she come
forward and say he's having all of these
problems why is he different I I don't
think she has any incentive to do that
in fact she would have the incentive to
do the opposite
um
so
um I think that the best evidence out
there is the reports of the people that
know Terry best
um you've heard of the term eggshell
plaintiff
I have not okay
uh you've heard of people being more
sensitive to injury than others correct
uh I don't know that's a term but but
sure or the concept you've heard of the
concept
and uh
so it's possible that Terry was more
sensitive to an injury such as what
occurred on
at Deer Valley in the ski crash and
others and that's a risk factor or
something that may have caused him more
injury than another person would have
had
does that make sense and what do you how
do you respond to that well I would
respond that Terry had a he sustained a
significant injury he was knocked out he
had four broken ribs so I don't know
that that's an eggshell that's that's a
pretty significant Force
um
whether or not he would have recovered
or recovered quickly
there are lots of people that don't get
better after
traumatic brain injury
we typically see that from car accidents
but you know some people just aren't
right after an injury and
um
I think Terry Falls in that category
just a moment
I have no more questions thank you
I think we'll just tell
pardon me can we go five minutes why
don't you approach
Mr Egan you may proceed
may I begin your honor
Dr Gibby good to see you again uh I have
a couple questions uh before we break
for lunch about uh this comment that you
made about Mr Sanderson having a good
relationship with his daughters
you read some of their testimony is that
correct
I did and uh do you recall reading uh
about Jenny Sanderson one of his
daughters
um
I I don't remember the names exactly but
I'm okay you can refresh my memory the
one was
I think the the one that I recall
reading was the
oldest daughter that had a granddaughter
that just graduated from high school and
then there was another one
that um
so there are only two two depositions of
the two so maybe you can tell me the
names and I will sure well I'll just ask
you things that I mean maybe came up in
some of the others so Jenny uh the
youngest
um she testified that she did not feel
loved or nurtured by her father growing
up did you read about that
I didn't read her deposition then
because I did not see any of that uh of
that testimony and this may have been
discussed in some of the other daughters
depositions so I'll just keep reading in
case you read uh read about any of these
other statements uh there's also
testimony that Mr Sanderson was
domineering and emotionally and verbally
abusive to Jenny and her mother Tana do
you recall reading anything about that
no I I do recall some testimony about uh
him being angry with the
man that was having fear with his wife
and that that was atypical for him I
think
punched him or something but that was
listed as very typical in Terry's
okay what about uh did you hear any
testimony about Mr Sanderson
becoming frustrated if his expectations
weren't met and this is referring to his
children
uh no I don't recall that what about
testimony that he has always been easily
frustrated and quick to anger
um I think that testimony is
contradicted by other testimony by the
daughter but uh but no I was not aware
of that testimony okay what about
testimony that his frustration was
visible in his body language and in the
way he would talk
like I said I don't think I've read this
deposition
um
what about testimony that he did not
speak with one of his daughters Jenny
for 13 years
not aware of that
um what about testimony that Mr
Sanderson is controlling and
relentlessly tries to mold Jenny to be a
certain way
yeah again I haven't had any of the
testimony from Jenny okay I was not
given that deposition well some some of
these things may have been addressed by
the daughters sure as you mentioned with
the the
um
Fair there may be something that's
related and I want to give you an
opportunity to address it
have you read any testimony that Mr
Sanderson was hyper focused on success
and Compares his daughters to that
standard in a painful way
I did re I did read testimony about him
being very focused and one of the terms
was anal retentive
or anal or something like that that he
was that he was a very focused
individual and
um
a multitasker
but
not any
again I've not heard any of the negative
comments from this daughter and I'm not
sure what that relationship was whether
this was
from a previous marriage or you know
what happened there but okay not aware
of that okay what about testimony that
this daughter Jenny has taken breaks
from her father over the years because
he oversteps the boundaries she sets
um again
heaven read Jenny's testimony okay
that's all I have thanks
are you resting are you just resting for
lunch
okay all right we'll take a recess now
for lunch and we'll return at 1 30.
sure
and I guess we're in recess unless
there's anything that that the lawyers
need
all right if we have something anything
like what we needed to do this morning
where there was an objection to
testimony and I'm I guess I'm referring
to the defendants mostly right now if if
you could let the court know so
hopefully we could handle that in not in
the jury time we can come earlier in the
morning we can work over lunch we can do
things after five so that would be
helpful
I missed the very first part of that if
you have any objections to testimony
that may require you know examining the
witness out of the hearing of the jury
or substantial argument let's try to do
that uh I mean for example if you're
preparing tonight and you all of a
sudden realize you've got something
email the clerk we can email the other
lawyers and or email the other lawyers
and the clerk and we can come in at 8 30
if we need to so yeah
for C1
or if the next Witness
Paulie who is one of the daughters sure
that there are some issues uh that I I
do want
to have come out and I don't want to get
a like a character objection
but I also don't want to have a hearing
before so
uh maybe I'll try to give you a
forewarning because that's I think the
very next witness and let's go well it's
next if it's if it's the subject of
emotion and Lemony order is that what
you're talking about where the courts
precise words like yeah I mean you said
607 okay 608 I want to hear before and
there are some issues that um
I think may impact
both okay and let me come back about 15
minutes early you think that would be
enough well let me just ask
Goldstein is next yeah we don't want to
keep him waiting and we thought we'd be
long done
Paul the doctor give me so we're gonna
finish Dr Gibby and then our doctor
sounds like there's some extensive
cross-examination of Gibby I don't know
what extensive means but are you asking
if Dr Goldsmith can begin at 1 30. no
okay
but we need to get it done today thank
you
all right I'll just let me withdraw my
statement right now I'm just sort of say
I can see some things with the daughters
that may come up okay okay and
back at 1 30. back at 1 30. thanks how
much
I'm thinking a nap
now all right thank you
foreign
may be seated thank you Mr Sykes
Sam Goldstein
hey do you swear that the testimony you
are about to give in the case now before
the court will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you God thank you good afternoon
would you please take your full name and
address Sam Goldstein 230 South 500 East
Suite 100 Salt Lake City Utah 84102
where where were you born and where did
you grow up
I was born in Jersey City New Jersey in
moved to Brooklyn New York in 1955. grew
up there went to school there
came to Salt Lake City in 1976 to finish
my doctorate and I've been here ever
since the Yankees fan or a Mets fan
uh well I have to honor my dear departed
father a Yankees fan there you go
okay
um
and did you do graduate work just at the
University of Utah or any other
universities I did graduate work at
Montclair State in New Jersey and at the
University of Utah any fellowships or
special training opportunities
I'm not sure I can answer the question I
finished my degree and did up a doctoral
residency to sit for my license
which I did the license is generic in
the state of Utah so your license is a
psychologist and an ethically
responsible to practice within the area
in which you've been trained
and you have uh
uh specialty areas or interest area
should call in both children and adults
is that correct in my clinical work yes
primarily children in my clinical work
okay
and uh tell us tell a jury about your
Publications would you
what would you like me to tell them
summarize in less than three minutes
uh my 54th book just came out a large
number of clinical texts textbooks that
are used by other professionals trade
books for the general public I added a
major science journal comes out 14 times
a year on attention and related problems
it's 2 000 pages of peer-reviewed
research I've authored or co-authored a
dozen psychological tests and
neuropsychological tests that are used
all over the world
tell us about uh some of those tests
what the what they show or intended to
show well the one I'm most proud of the
cognitive assessment system is a measure
of someone's critical thinking and
problem solving that's independent of
the effects of culture or experience so
Aboriginal children in the outback
affluent children in Suburbia at the
same ages test the same way so we
created that instrument to avoid the
bias of children coming from
underprivileged homes or minorities
being unfairly identified as having
disabilities in the schools
okay
now uh we're going to talk about this in
a few minutes
but I'd like you to tell the jury
briefly
what exactly the function it's executive
function
what I think it is
what what it is scientifically in the
field of neuropsychology well there's a
lot of disagreement in what it is it's
become a very popular term in education
now but primarily it refers to how you
do what you do it's the strategies or
behaviors you employ in solving whatever
problems you have in the course of your
day some people believe it's a variety
of different kinds of abilities memory
emotional regulation planning
in our research it seems to be an
overarching a singular phenomena how you
do what you do anything you do to
improve outcome would be an executive
function your preparation for this trial
for my examination would be considered
an executive function improving what you
hope to achieve in my testimony and in
everyday life it's how we do what we do
have you have you published in this area
my co-edited textbook on Executive
functioning is the most widely used in
the world I'm told and my assessment
tool the comprehensive executive
functioning inventory is standardized on
the general population of children and
adults and we use it as an observational
measure so a parent would fill it out or
a teacher or an individual asking
questions about how they do what they do
how do you plan how do you regulate your
emotions it's different from the kind of
neuropsychological testing most people
think of when you think of someone
sitting across a computer or face to
face with an evaluator being asked
questions or putting puzzles together
Etc this is more about how you do it's
more about Behavior okay
can a person hypothetically
score really high a bright person
a person of some substance or education
score really high
on neuropsychological testing
of things like
words and Concepts
and do really poorly on Executive
function so you mean someone like
Einstein Einstein or Terry Sanderson or
Terry Sanderson correct our
neuropsychological tests measure your
ability to think critically your memory
how you go about solving problems in a
controlled environment but the
relationship of those tests to real
world behavior is fairly limited so you
can be very bright
particularly if you have a brain injury
to the front of your brain
yeah orbital frontal the lower frontal
part you can be still very very bright
intellectually Advanced and still have a
lot of trouble in everyday life
perseverating going over things again
and again finding it difficult to
problem solve repeating yourself trouble
controlling your emotions again you use
the term executive functioning any
behavior that you engage in to
demonstrate what you know in an
effective way knowing it isn't enough
you have to know how to execute it you
have to know how to do it okay
uh
these do people sometimes
uh short search at that and common
everyday products and saying being able
to keep two balls in the air three balls
in the air at one time
I don't understand the question what was
the question
some of the case need to come up here in
the snow in the ice
okay
yeah you have things to worry about at
home too
so you kind of Juggle all these things
executive function help you do that
the ability to think about one thing and
put something else out of your mind yeah
absolutely again any Behavior you engage
in whether it's internal in your
thinking or external in how you do what
you do if it improves your performance
and your functioning it falls under that
umbrella
over your career okay
roughly what 19
to the present so the clinic I opened
with a neurologist we opened in 1980
okay we see about five or six hundred
children and a few hundred adults every
year right through covid about half the
people I see have brain injuries the
other half have more complicated genetic
or related kinds of Developmental
problems you don't want to see me you
don't want your children or any of your
relatives to have to see me they're not
all in litigation I do about one
litigation forensic case a week I don't
know if that's been explained to the
jury but in a forensic matter I'm not
treating I'm simply retained and I am a
retained expert so I'd like to think
that I'm unbiased that I'm not an
advocate but I am retained by one side
or another to offer opinions and answer
questions
roughly by the plaintiff side the
defense side we're playing the fear I'm
asked that all the time and my response
is it doesn't matter because I'm not an
advocate my opinions will be the same I
would hope I make that effort regardless
of who I'm testifying for I would argue
given that the rules now require me to
keep seven years worth of Records it's
about even
between plaintiff and defense correct no
over the course of your career since
about 1980
talking about 43 years
give or take
how many neuropsychological evaluations
have been performed in your clinic
in my clinic by me or by myself and my
post my doctoral residents
it's roughly as I've testified seven or
eight hundred a year
again they're not all in litigation it's
grown the first 10 years it was smaller
it's grown over the years but last year
it was about 700 evaluations I'm talking
about roughly I missed a country lawyer
okay I'm not very smart
where I can do a little bit of math
that's talking about sixteen thousand
neurose technological evaluations 700 a
year times times 10 is seven is seven
thousand times 20 is 14 000. it's a lot
yes okay and how many of those have you
done personally I do about 200 a year
about four a week when I'm in the clinic
again they're not all in litigation and
two-thirds are children
uh in my clinic in my forensic work uh
it's about the other way around I think
in my deposition I I said it was 50 50 I
think it's probably closer to 70 30
because we spend the majority of Our
Lives as adults sure so it wouldn't be
unexpected in litigation a significant
percentage of people with brain injuries
or I might be involved will be an adult
versus a child now and all of those
evaluations
always nice sixteen thousand in the
clinics and
several thousand multiple thousands for
you personally
have you ever
issued a report or done an evaluation
without seeing the individual and
interviewing the individual
who's the center of the of the case ever
not in an evaluation I've been asked to
do record reviews that's a very
different matter
so uh
how important is it
if you're going to get a legitimate
opinion
to to do a clinical meeting with the
individual
well and again it that I don't mean to
be difficult but it matters what opinion
if I if I conduct a record review the
opinions I offer are the accuracy of the
foundation treaters or other experts
have provided informing their opinions
so my review asks the question does this
person provide sufficient Foundation
that's a term you attorneys use
sufficient facts to support the opinions
they've offered but as someone doing a
record review I can't offer my own
opinion so
you're when you do a record review
you're looking at evaluating the testing
done by others right and and the medical
records and the care uh provided but I
can't offer my own opinion I can
disagree with the opinions of others
based on what I perceive as their lack
of foundation but you can't offer your
own opinion
as to the neuropsychological status
of somebody without doing a clinical
interview is that correct
I could but it would would be both
unethical and unscientific how how can I
offer an opinion based on the data
someone else gathered without Gathering
my own data maybe I would ask questions
a little differently maybe I would
observe the patient somewhat differently
so I can't offer opinions about the
opinions of others but I can't offer my
own opinions unless I actually see the
person
so would it be true that seeing the
person is important if you're going to
offer an opinion in court about the
person yes absolutely okay
how important
oh well in my work it would be at least
99 important
maybe in the legal Arena it might be 51
important what do you say a minute ago
you said unethical what do you mean by
that
well if you're a member of the American
Psychological Association
one of the standards of Ethics is you
don't provide independent opinions about
a person unless you've seen them or
there are other circumstances that might
preclude you from seeing them like
they're dead or something
it could be their dad could be in a
forensic setting opposing counsel
refuses to make their their client
available
now uh you've done a lot of medical
legal work mentioned that are you
familiar with the rule 35 exam sometimes
called an ime independent medical exam
that allows you to request to see
somebody
sure
okay
um
what percentage
of
your your clinical practice is children
versus adults I may have covered that
but I wanted to be sure of hand yeah I
mentioned that it's in in my clinical
practice it's at least two-thirds
children all right
uh and
how often do you see victims of
concussion
adults victims of concussion in the
clinical practice or forensic Focus or
both
at least someone every week that's part
big part of what I do okay
uh
uh how is
did you do neuropsychologists sometimes
if they're trained determine causation
of a concussion
some will yes and how do you do that
uh review medical records have an
understanding and appreciation of a
diagnostic process understand the
symptoms of concussion as well as
understanding the liabilities of of
determining the causality of those
symptoms and coming to a conclusion in a
forensic matter I defer to the diagnosis
of a concussion to a physician
preferably within uh proximity to an
event it's just easier for the jury I
think to understand what each expert's
role is
okay
um
now could you tell the jury briefly
what information you reviewed and relied
on in this case
I don't know if I can do that briefly
but your office provide well your office
provided me with a long set of Records
and depositions from multiple providers
both before and after this particular
accident
and that's what I used I I don't
foundation for my opinion a few minutes
ago I explained about the importance of
the foundation in terms of the facts you
offer to support your opinion there are
a lot of Records I receive that don't
have anything to do with the questions
you're asking me to address if in any
way I think a record might reflect that
I will put it into my report and as
Foundation
the Jew review uh medical records from
the clinic in Park City
I looked at them yes did you review the
the records from the medical
uh building in at the Deer Valley Ski
Resort yes okay
did you review the VA records the ones
that were provided to me yes
did you review Dr Fong's records yes
uh was there anything important in the
Deer Valley incident report
dated 226 16 for your opinions
important in my conclusion that this man
was suffering the consequences of a
brain injury yes concussion Arrangement
yeah he was he was uh disoriented a bit
um
he his head cleared pretty quickly it it
seemed like again these are fairly
cursory examinations but there are
indications in in the records and then
subsequently a care provider indicates
that it's their opinion that his
symptoms are reflective of a concussion
and I don't question care providers I
wasn't there
and and why is why are those things
important for you
well they're more important for you than
for me in a clinical setting I'm asked
to evaluate someone and offer opinions
about their problems and what might help
them in a forensic setting I'm also
asked do I have an opinion about who's
responsible or what event might be
responsible and in a chronology from
looking at all of the records and
evaluating Mr Sanderson the one event
that would appear to acutely lead to the
symptoms he was presenting was this
particular accident
ski Collision the ski Collision correct
now uh this the day of the Collision
Michael McMahon MC capital m a h a n a
physician's assistant
evaluated uh
Terry Sanderson and he wrote quote
patient collided with another skier end
of quote this is an admitted record
uh it's not significant for you
again at an event that might cause an
injury to his head any factual
information that would help that would
be significant but again I'm not
determining again whether Mr McMahon
made an accurate assessment or not I'm
simply taking the record as it appears
and there are multiple indications in
the records of symptoms that are
consistent with a head injury another
thing he says when I quote states he
lost Consciousness end of quote it's not
significant and if so why
it again it's a symptom that would be
consistent with a head injury how the
the patient in this case Mr Sanderson
was aware of that uh isn't in that
record so I don't know how he decided he
was or was not unconscious sometimes
people are disoriented and they consider
that being unconscious sometimes people
are in shock and they're not really
unconscious other times they are truly
unconscious for short periods or for
lengthy periods of time he also wrote
quote complaints of mild headache and
the quote is that significant for your
opinions in any way
again with the caveat that headaches
could be caused by all kinds of
phenomena including a brain injury
quote patient was unconscious for an
undetermined length of time close quote
is that significant yes
the same reason you already expressed
yes also quote has a sense of dullness
and dullness is in interior quotes in
the front of his head close Club
is that significant and why
again for the same reasons the term
dullness fog our interesting
descriptions that people will offer when
they're experiencing difficulty
functioning in everyday life sometimes
it's hard to know exactly what they mean
by my head feels dull
and it says that he states he was quote
disoriented for a period of time after
the injury disoriented for a period of
time after the injury is that
significant yes again all significant
that all of these could be markers of of
a head injury or a closed head injury in
this case
now are you aware that uh
the very next day
um
Mr sanderson's uh
girlfriend fiance took him to the VA
27th of February
did you read those records yeah the
complaints made
from memory can you uh recall some of
those things that were complained of I
can show them to you but you recall well
again he he'd been a patient there on an
ongoing basis for many years he had some
pre-existing issues
um that might have made him what you
refer to in your field as an
asymptomatic eggshell plaintiff meaning
he had some problems that were not
causing him difficulty in life uh that
then proceeded to cause him difficulty
in life but he the description was the
same types of concussive symptoms uh
headache irritability maybe a loss of
consciousness
confusion problems with concentration
again they could have multiple
ideologies people with chronic pain who
report those symptoms people who've been
psychologically traumatized will report
those symptoms so they are indicators
that something is wrong in an acute way
over time the conclusion has been that
they are related to a brain injury they
also did a
uh an MRI I believe maybe it was a CT
but they wrote and the interpretation
ventricular system discordant discordant
with mild volume loss
do you understand those words
discordant with my mild volume loss well
I'm going to have to preface this with
um I'm not a neurologist or a
neuradiologist or I'm a
neuropsychologist it he has enlarged
ventricles
but he's asymptomatic for high pressure
hydrocephalus it's no clear no volume
also after seven years right and no
change correct no acute change in the
brain
he was discharged that day with a
warning
for quote mild traumatic brain injury
and then it said parentheses concussion
minor had injury trauma posted injury
what significance is that
again it's an indication that the
treater was under the impression that
these symptoms were related to a
concussion or might be related to a
cushion and was cautioning him initially
what when someone hits their head and
there isn't a break in the skull or a
bleed it's referred to as a closed head
injury and typically within a few days
it's referred to as a concussion
sometimes sooner if it persists then
sometimes it's referred to as a
persistent or post-concussive disorder
and if it lasts forever which it seems
to do in a small percentage of people
for reasons we don't understand we call
it a persistent post-concussive disorder
okay
and the
the
paperwork he was given
he was told to watch for signs quote as
long as one year after the injury close
quote
why would somebody so why would someone
be given that kind of a warning
again I don't know I didn't author of
that document and I think we have to
make a distinction between symptoms and
consequences
so with brain injury one of the rules of
thumb is that symptoms are most present
at the time of the injury and over time
those symptoms will typically remit
consequence is different the
consequences whatever the impact of
those symptoms might be and over time
for some people consequences cause
increasing dysfunction and increasing
impairment in their lives as those
symptoms disrupt their relationships
their ability to work the quality of
their emotional regulation so again I
think what they were cautioning him is
he may still see some consequences over
time we wouldn't expect again the
majority of people with mild brain
injury within a year to a year and a
half are better
okay
did you do neuropsychological testing
paper and pencil testing and interviews
well let's just take the paper mentioned
resting did you do
neuropsychological testing on Terry
Sanderson
we did a full battery of
neuropsychological tests looking at his
abilities so abilities are defined as
those innate differences among us some
people have better memory better speed
of processing better attention or
organization I looked at his knowledge
what does he know and finally I looked
at his skill and skill as a verb
skillfully doing things which he was
having trouble with it's not a noun it's
not reading skill so that's how I frame
the assessment and the tests aren't used
to prove or disprove brain injury they
they're not capable of doing that
they're designed to look at how he
functions relative to people in the
general population or how we might
function relative to people with his
academic and Vocational background and
in particular in this man's case because
I was seeing him quite some time after
the injury I already had an indication
he'd been tested a number of times
before that his problems were more
behavioral emotional regulation fronto
temporal kinds of problems I didn't
expect them to show up on the
neuropsychological testing
you know I I'm looking at your test
evaluation here it's
dozens of pages uh dated
May well I think it's a data valuation
May 7 and May 2020. correct so about
three years ago correct and and quite a
bit of time after his accident yeah
uh as an accident was February of 16. so
about four years later correct now
generally Dr Goldstein here your
experience
uh
uh when when do you know that a person's
condition is permanent in terms of time
what's the rule of thumb
what's the condition
yeah in other words uh if a person isn't
better in four years what does it tell
you about his condition
again I don't mean to be difficult are
we talking about brain injury yeah brain
injury I'm sorry oh if we're talking
about brain injury by two years out you
can compensate you can learn strategies
to function better but in terms of
recovery of the brain it probably won't
happen
okay
and uh
you know roughly how many tests you gave
him
depends what you define as a test
well he was asked to complete a number
of self-report measures right some
people call those tests I don't okay uh
he was asked to complete a number of
face-to-face measures those are tests
probably about a dozen to 15 it was one
he became quite stressed that looks at
his ability to process information uh
and he didn't he didn't we didn't do it
because he came distressed became
distressed about it I think we did one
measure to look at his what's referred
to as effort whether he's making effort
is he malingering or dissimulating I
didn't have any indication he was doing
that and the battery of tests is
designed to look at his abilities
his knowledge and then for someone in
his circumstances how skillfully he can
use those two to solve whatever problems
I put in front of him now
uh do competent neuropsychologists
when they do a test battery on someone
like this
particularly someone who's involved in
litigation
okay I don't think I don't know what
stage this was in it four years
uh but uh
are there are there tasks built into
tests to test validation
validation is it a valid response
there are two kinds of we call validity
measures meaning is the person making
decent effort right uh one kind or
Standalone they're specifically designed
for that
I administered one of those measures to
him he passed a hundred percent
there are others that are embedded
within a test meaning the test was
designed for one thing but I'm going to
use it to look at something else I'm not
a big fan of those and the way you use
those if the person performs more poorly
than 99 percent of people you raise some
questions about whether they're making
adequate effort or or trying to make a
mountain out of a molehill of their
problems but in Mr sanderson's case in
none of the previous assessments two
psychologists a speech pathologist
and my assessment no one's ever raised
the question that he's not making effort
the question has been raised is why he's
so repetitive why he's so obsessive
there's never been a question raised
that he's not intellectually
brighter than most people that he
doesn't have advanced academic knowledge
none of those issues have ever come up
bottom line
did you see any evidence of malingering
not making sufficient effort
okay factitious disorder
seeking secondary games secondary gain
any of that no nothing no
um
did you review the reports of Dr Fong
Debbie in vain yes okay
did you review the reports at some point
of doctors uh
eastvold and Ashkenazi psychologists uh
hired by the defense
I read them yes I wouldn't consider them
reports they are record reviews record
reviews right
all right could you review the record
reviews of Dr Black Dr Ashley and Dr
hosh yes they're Physicians so I don't
take exception with their opinions no
I'd like to ask you a question
based on what you've just told the jury
you have enough information
about this case
to answer these three questions I want
to ask you about the answer again
um
well let's type that
can you tell me
based on your review
the things you've just told us about
what are the three most important things
about this case that stuck out to you
sure and I and I think I
suggested to you that because human
beings are complicated and lots of
information comes at jurors that when I
testify I like the jury to remember
three things and now you're giving my
secret I want to sure you think I'm
smart
and and so tell me what those three
things are that you think are important
for them to understand sure and the
first one involves Common Sense okay not
to leave your common sense at the door
because experts are offering all of
these opinions
Mr Sanderson may have had pre-existing
issues with his health with his mood
with his brain but there was based on
the records an acute adverse change in
his behavioral and emotional functioning
and initially it appeared to be a
consequence of his physical injuries he
was in pain and and quite a lot of pain
but over time it became apparent that it
was more than just him being disrupted
by pain and that were it not for that
particular accident the life he was
living in the six months to a year
before that I think the jury has heard
about would be the life he would
continue to be living so there was an
acute change not something slow and
Insidious over time characteristic of
Alzheimer's or white matter disease or
or any other Progressive illness in the
brain that's one
uh happens very quickly okay what's
number two uh number two is that these
pre-existing vulnerabilities he had
don't explain the acute change and now
the long-term change in his behavior and
and functioning uh that this is an acute
rapid downturn uh and and maybe he was
and I use the term an eggshell plaintiff
who was asymptomatic and maybe those
vulnerabilities as a consequence of his
injuries uh made it harder for him to
recover made him more symptomatic than
other people I don't necessarily can
tell you that for sure but I can tell
you that the problems he had before
his mood his anxiety his personality
style uh do are not the reasons he's
struggling today so they don't explain
what he's got today that those prior
things they don't explain the acute
change in his functioning
and the adverse pattern of emotions and
behavior and communication he presents
with in everyday life okay what's number
three
he's not malingering he's not a
malingering means you're just faking and
you know it
he's not dissimulating dissimulating
means you're making a mountain out of a
molehill you have a little problem in an
effort to recover or get some obtain
some secondary gain you make it seem
like it's a bigger problem and and
nowhere do I see his problem is lack of
effort he has diligently gone to the
treatment providers that have been
recommended to him uh I know his
treating uh neuropsychologists very well
she's an exceptional therapist and he
makes very little progress with her
because of his problems
um and you've you've covered some of
this but tell the the jury from it
standpoint of a neuropsychologist
what is a closed head brain injury what
is an mtvi you've heard that
well the small M and the capital TBI so
it's an injury to the brain that hasn't
cracked the skull and and doesn't tear
the dura uh that the the head is still
intact but the brain has been injured
into I can offer a little Foundation if
you'd like to explain how that happens
so the brain is connected to the spinal
cord and it just kind of floats around
and the skull evolved to protect the
brain from blows like this over millions
of years not just in our species but in
earlier species so the skull absorbs a
lot of force when you hit over the head
and that was primarily the kind of brain
injuries people had until we started
moving fast in vehicles
and now most of injuries that people
have are acceleration deceleration or
turning and twisting and not so much
something hitting the brain from the
outside the front of the brain rests on
the criboform plate which is a bony part
of the brain that lets the brain fit
very nicely and if the brain is moving
40 miles an hour and suddenly stops the
brain inside your head goes like this
twists around and it rubs up against the
skull and you get particularly frontal
injuries that lead to disruption in
behavior in mood regulation in emotional
regulation in in socialization it's
pretty classic and fairly common in in
those kinds of acceleration injuries
it's not called a front lobe damage it's
called a frontal lobe injury that's
correct and and the brain is probably
120 billion moving Parts it's not like a
computer each part may be connected to
up to 50 000 other parts at any given
moment one brain cell might be
communicating with 5 000 other brain
cells simultaneously we we don't
understand really how the brain works
and we absolutely don't understand how
the mind works the mind is this an
abstract creation of the physical brain
and as I've testified in my deposition I
think Terry's problems today are equally
reflective of his mind and his thinking
and his obsessions as they are of damage
to his brain now let's suppose
I'll hold my hand out here
and a cup did you see that
that's the skull and inside my fist is
the brain okay my Knuckles are the front
if someone gets knocked down on a ski
run and falls down and and hits the
the snow hard
okay
is the brain going to slosh forward
sometimes and strike the inside of that
skull
I'm gonna first have to state that I'm
I'm not an accident reconstruction
expert I can tell you that that any
acceleration deceleration of the head
will lead the brain like a like a rubber
ball inside a jar of liquid to bounce
around but but I can't testify that the
forces that were incurred in this
accident were sufficient to damage the
brain that's beyond my expertise but
you've seen people that have had
injuries like that is that correct
correct it has a sudden deceleration
it's it's the most common kind of injury
and and unfortunately up until maybe 100
or 150 years ago if you had a brain
injury you died
so the brain really has no way of
of repairing itself as far as we're
aware and the brain has no temp agency
meaning if one part of the brain is
damaged as an adult another part of the
brain doesn't step up and rewire and
that's very nice pop psychology but it
really doesn't apply especially in
adults now in children it may to some
extent but not in adults now uh we've
heard the term
A post-concussion syndrome
yeah is that also
uh one of the uh
words or
Expressions that she used to express uh
mild traumatic brain injury yes a mild
traumatic brain is just the equivalent
of concussion if your brain injury is
more severe meaning you have a bleed
you're unconscious for longer periods of
time we typically don't refer to that as
a concussion we refer to that as a as a
moderate to severe brain injury
experience are people required to have
loss of consciousness to have a mild
brain injury or a post-concussion
syndrome no it's not just my experience
it's the standard in the field okay so
you've studied this and that's something
you know personally
I know it from my clinical practice I
know it from my training I know it from
my qualifications which is I think the
three requirements for me to sit here on
the stand I'd like to ask you about your
opinions in this case you've already
given some
you don't want to be uh repetitive here
but uh
uh
on gen February 26 2016.
to Terry Sanderson have a concussion
you're asking for my opinion or my
review of the records view the records
in your opinion the review of the
records demonstrating at a concussion
okay did this result in a traumatic
brain injury
uh the his behavior over time and his
treatment by others and has continued to
treatment today argues that it has
and uh I think you've already talked
about the cause do you believe uh what
was the cause in your opinion
I'm not asking who hit whom but the
cause
the cause of his concussion yes uh the
forces his brain was uh exposed to
during that event
now uh
you have uh
noted
in your deposition you were asked a lot
about
Thai test scores we talked about that a
little bit
um
many areas Terry scores
exceptionally lying
okay
on
measures of
of intellectual
experience and achievement
is that inconsistent with having a brain
injury
of the kind you've described
no explain that
well it
let's look at the foundation of what
you've just asked
if if an IQ test or a memory test or a
measure of list learning told you
everything you needed to know about
everything the brain does that would be
fine
but we find that neuropsychological
tests tell us something about everyday
life
but they fall far short of telling us
the majority and in his case individuals
with this kind of frontal injury and
again he may have been an eggshell
person waiting to have a problem but
individuals with his kind of an injury
typically have intact neuropsychological
testing you can't look at his IQ scores
and argue his IQ is normal therefore he
hasn't had an injury
and the other side of it is maybe his IQ
was even higher and now it's just High
maybe he's lost IQ I'm not testifying to
that because I don't think he's lost
intelligence or I don't think any of the
neuropsych testing really demonstrates
the problems he has from this accident
the problems he asked from this accident
are orbital frontal emotional regulation
Behavior socialization impulsive
responding the kinds of stuff that you
better understand if you follow someone
around for two weeks but I'm really
afforded that opportunity how does um
let's suppose that uh
or others
have pre-existing problems let's say
they get a anger anger a little bit too
easily
okay
so they have pre-existing
uh issues psychologically
uh irritability let's say
um how does
a traumatic brain injury that as you
have described affect those pre-existing
problems in your experience
it accelerates them it irritates them
that's a good question but we see it in
in dementia in Alzheimer's patients as
well
as they age and as their brain begins to
have more problems their good qualities
seem to fade away and whatever adverse
qualities they had in life seem to be
Amplified we don't really understand why
that is could be something to do with
the mind as opposed to the physical
brain but it's true if someone had a
history of depression and they have a
brain injury odds are whatever
depression they experience after either
from the brain injury or from experience
will be worse and it will be harder for
them to recover if they had pre-existing
ADHD if they were impulsive and
inattentive before it would be harder
for them to recover any vulnerability
seems to be
one that will increase your
vulnerability to be more symptomatic in
a brain injury and decrease your ability
to recover
now with respect
there's a VA record and it's been
mentioned in this trial so far
February 2 2016 roughly
four weeks give or take prior to the ski
exit
and Terry Sanderson says in that record
I feel like an old man I I may not be
quoting that absolutely correctly
uh is that relevant to this case and
does it affect your opinions in any way
explain it doesn't affect my opinions
right it reinforces my reasons for not
questioning uh providers it reinforces
my reasons for why an evaluation has to
require some face-to-face interaction
because here we sit trying to understand
what this man meant by that statement
and we try and piece together context oh
they were discussing his weight or his
exercise or his age but in the end we
really don't know and and for me for a
70 what was he at the time a 70 year old
man to say I'm starting to feel a little
old uh 73 say he was 73 at the time and
well at the time of well she well when
he was 69. yeah it was 69. so it
wouldn't be unexpected for him to tell
his position you know I'm I'm starting
to feel a little old I'm slowing down we
don't know what took place maybe the
physician then said well are you skiing
less and Terry would have said maybe no
are you uh doing less volunteer work
maybe Terry would have said no we
weren't there and and my experience as a
provider because I I spend the majority
of my time working with people is I
don't write everything down I'm not
every case is not a forensic matter in
which I make note of every indication
they could have had a long conversation
about the fact that yeah he was feeling
old but he was still doing all the
things he did before I don't know
opposed of the contracts then we'll see
this later but in that same
visit he says I'm eating out too much
I'm not exercising enough
it's not significant
significant of what
to to connect why he's feeling old
you're going to have to ask him okay
because I again I don't know the context
with which he offered those opinions
but that could be relevant could it not
it could be relevant to his
post-accident problems no why he's
feeling old on February too oh I see
you're you're making a cause and effect
connection he's not exercising he's not
eating and and therefore he says
um it's an indication I'm getting old I
don't have the energy to do what I did
before but I'm not depressed which I
think is something else was mentioned
yeah it could be relevant and he has a
plan to deal with
he has a plan to deal with it according
to what he tells the physician yes
I read in a
2010 article
um
something about and this was dealing
with the neuropsychological assessment
of the orbital and ventromedial
prefruncal cortex
there was a lot of complicated words I'm
a simple country lawyer explain to me
what that means front of the brain okay
very simple very simple there's there's
different parts of the front of the
brain but it's the front of the brain
the the last evolving parts of our brain
the most recently evolving parts of our
brain uh and and uh older animals don't
have very big frontal lobes they evolved
later on
uh and they're the seed of rationality
so uh they're The Logical parts of the
brain as opposed to the middle parts of
the brain which are more emotionally
driven babies are born like Klingons
two-year-olds look like they have
bipolar disorder because it's the middle
of the brain that runs the show for them
and maturation is about the front of the
brain both myelinating the the nerves
growing sheaths so they fire properly
but also about acquiring the knowledge
to think before you act and not just
always brain dance which is a term I use
to to act just On Emotion
this article hypothetically says that
pay for intentional tests of these areas
do not capture
the range of real world abnormalities
existed exhibited by these patients
these tasks don't capture the real world
abnormalities
exhibited by these patients what does
that mean to you and is it significant
in this case well it's significant in
this case
and it's what I've just testified to and
that is and you're using the term paper
and pencil I would prefer to say the
battery of neuropsychological tests not
not the questionnaires completed by
family members because one of the things
I do as part of an assessment is I
always want to talk to a family member
if it's the parent of a child or a
teacher or a spouse because particularly
in this kind of a problem the way the
person sees themselves is often not the
way other people see them and that
person is often confused about why other
people don't want to talk to them or be
with them or respond the way they do to
them because their Insight is limited
another limitation of a front of the
brain injury
okay
um you were asked about
the VA assessments done
I think before and after tereshe
uh City Collision sea crash
uh
are your opinions in contradiction with
those of the VA people that looked at
him why or why not
looked at him immediately following the
accident well yeah within the next year
and a half
no then relative to this matter I don't
have an opinions about his other medical
problems but relative to this matter
this matter they're not different no
okay
uh
in your opinion what effect did the
ski collision and what happened to him
there
um
uh have to do with his
Stress and Anxiety
well I think two things happened to him
I think one
that and we've already talked a little
bit about it this was a man who was
talkative boisterous a little over the
top at times and and that pattern
because of his frontal lobe injury
accelerated to the point where after 15
minutes it's hard to have a conversation
with him
he's repetitive and goes around in
circles and he's very bright and very
intellectual if you're discussing some
intellectual matter but when you're
discussing his State of Affairs his
personal life
he he obsesses about it the second thing
I think that's happened to him is his
mind
meaning the way he comes to think about
what's happening to him in his life and
and some of that may be from brain
injury some of that's just his lifetime
personality style but he has become
obsessed with trying to return himself
to the level of functioning he perceived
he had before this accident and I I may
not judgment what now say that again the
assessment his assessment of the life he
had before he's obsessed with getting
back to that he's obsessed with getting
back to that he he and I had a
discussion that that not every problem
he encountered in everyday life when he
couldn't remember where he put his keys
not every problem was a consequence of
injury suffered in this accident some of
that was just normal age and for me the
primary consequence was his emotional
and behavioral regulation and then the
impact it had on his mind his perception
of who he is and who he was from his
view he is not the person he was from
his view he has lost Terry Sanderson and
this is what he said to me at one point
when I interviewed him
okay now
um
is there any cure
for uh
a concussion is there any cure for a
mild traumatic brain injury
cure meaning a treatment that makes it
get better yeah
not as far as I'm aware no there are
there are treatments that can help you
recover acquired knowledge which is
different from ability there are
activities that could help you make more
of whatever you have improve your memory
as it were but we don't really know of
any way to force the brain to heal
itself again as I've testified it's not
an arm or a leg Evolution doesn't afford
the opportunity by natural selection for
people whose arms were injured and
healed better to then have Offspring and
others who didn't to not have Offspring
in this case people with brain injuries
up until just recently in history died
so the brain doesn't really know how to
heal itself now this kind of a mild
traumatic ring of
Arena no why
well for my view the MRI is like looking
at the moon with binoculars right you're
not looking at a cellular level you're
not evaluating how brain cells fire how
many dendrites are connected to how many
other dendrites how axons work I think
Dr Gibby testified some to that but
again we're talking about a system of
over a hundred billion moving parts
um
does Terry singing a psychologist at the
VA well I know this is the VA named
Sabers are you aware of that Terry sees
Dr sieber she's a board-certified
neuropsychologist she sees him in
counseling she Dr sieber's works for
Intermountain Health Care and she works
with brain injured patients as a
therapist does that kind of therapy help
your honor may be approachable sure
no thank you
excuse me
you're certainly you can stretch your
legs beat your honor if I may
you know I usually would come back I'm
doing a TED talk tomorrow okay so if I
don't have any flicks I can go back
just the receiver I mean any do you need
to address it any further are you going
to go into it anymore Mr Sykes I was
going to ask him to do in the first
place was this neuropsychological uh
treatment help Terry cope that's it are
you going to go into it anymore by name
sea Rich by name okay
okay so we we want to get done with the
doctor today right and he wants to and
I'm sure Bob wants to all we're asking
for is equal time
so if he's been going yeah so far
did you verify that or is that just I
had it written in my notes 2 45 is when
he started okay I believe you and let's
not forget your honor that we wasted an
hour almost an hour no we're not talking
about that we're talking about this
don't conflate the two we could we can
deal with that issue if you'd like but
but what I want to do is on a pragmatic
level figure out how to complete this
witness so let's just hear a commitment
like I'm gonna take five more minutes or
I'm going to take 10 more minutes
but certainly we we got to take over by
four if we take over by four we'll be
okay is that fair sure
all right so if you can wrap up by four
o'clock Mr Sykes will be good we'll get
the jury in here as quickly as possible
okay yeah
would you let the other bailiff know
that as soon as the jury is ready to
bring them in
thank you
foreign
let the record reflect parties and
counselor present may be seated
members of the jury are all here we're
on our on our last stretch of the day
Mr Sykes you may proceed
doctor
all right
here
talk about
in May of 2020
and I'm referring if you want to
go to page 29 of your report
you listed a lot of problems there
would you mind
telling a jury
as of May
your assessment of Terry's problems
tell the jury
his problems in everyday life as
mentioned I'm actually on your report
do you want me to read from the reporter
you want me to just tell you what I
thought tell me what they are
well at the time it was my opinion that
there was a significant an acute odd
adverse change in this man's everyday
life
that a particular event either the
experience of it or the physical trauma
ensuing as a consequence of it
had caused a significant change and this
man's excuse me and this man's everyday
life
and it manifested itself
primarily as a change in his behavior
or tell you what we'll just read them
and ask you if this is one you
identified sure difficult difficulty
remembering important things to do yes
difficult remembering names of people
right again this is these are the things
he reported to me yeah
staying involved in activities due to
fatigue yes cognition problems he
reported that to me attention problems
yes memory problems yes frustration yes
learning new information yes
uh meeting daily responsibilities yes
Health maintenance yes excessively
talkative yes you observed that didn't
you
yes yeah
yeah understanding directions yes
switching attention from one stimulus to
another
yes depression
yes
no
any other problems that come to your
mind
what you found or observed
in your in your May 2020 evaluation
well again the list you just provided
was what he told me
and I tried to help him understand that
some of those items on the list I
thought were a consequence of his brain
injury
some of them I thought were a
consequence of how his mind was
processing what was going on in his life
and some of those I thought were just
the process of normal aging
that there wasn't any indication that he
he couldn't learn new information he
thought he couldn't learn new
information uh you gave him your
executive function test right
that's the questionnaire that he filled
out and then but he also took a number
of other face-to-face measures during
testing what what percentile did you
rank him
after looking at everything that he
answered in your own evaluation
I'm talking about Paige
anyway do you remember the percentile
you gave him sure and Justice Foundation
this is an instrument that he fills out
it asks questions about strategy how you
manage attention manage your emotions
whether you start things how you plan so
it's his self-report there is and you
ask me about validity measures there is
a check in there I developed this
instrument it's used very widely issues
worldwide it's used all over yeah in
multiple languages
there's a check in there to see if
someone's over reporting
making themselves look too good right
Under reporting trying to make
themselves uh or look too bad or look
too good he didn't indicate that based
on his self-assessment he was in the
bottom 16 percent for individuals of his
age matched for the census so we matched
to the census because we want to wash
out differences in terms of Education or
ethnicity or where you live in the
country so this is a man he was a former
captain in the U.S army ran a
Eye Clinic
ran two
[Music]
um
clinics in Southern Idaho Optometry
clinics
in the 16th percentile
right low average for executive function
low average again based upon himself
reports compared to a normative sample
and I want you to um
day after tomorrow
I'd like you to talk to the jury about
what this is the I'm going to end with
this
kind of things
we might expect to see
and I'm just going to ask you about some
of these things I'll ask you to Define
some for the jury because they won't
know what it means okay
some of them won't
and then tell me if we're going to see
that with Terry's testimony and why
perseveration first of all what is
perseveration so
I don't mean to be unresponsive but you
use the word see what you will see is a
a good looking gentleman of 76 years of
age he will be dressed appropriately as
hygiene will be good he will present
himself as very normal he clearly from
some of the things he will say it'll
reflect an intelligent person that's
what you will see
what you will hear is a challenge in a
variety of ways and is it his ability to
stay on task to answer the questions not
because he's evasive but because he's
obsessive in his thinking to come to
your question perseveration means you go
over something again and again and again
and Terry will tell you that I I just
feel like I have to tell you again even
though you you tell him I got it you've
already told me three times he he it's
not enough for him inappropriate
repetition correct inappropriate
repetition inability to take the
perspective of the other person and
appreciate they already got this I can
move on Mr jury I'd like you to see that
with him yes okay what about overly
talkative I think we're the time we're
supposed to take over your honor all
right we'll let you finish this line of
questioning go ahead
how about overly talkative yes
okay
how about irrelevant
Irrelevant in a sense that you'll ask
him a question his answer will be
unresponsive his answer will be about
something tangential to whatever the
question is
how about indirect answers
indirect meaning he has to go to China
to get across the street he may do that
yes is that a front and low problem yes
are always frontal load problems yes
what about digression what is digression
and are they likely to see that
uh the the colloquial is I digress
meaning we're discussing a particular
topic and suddenly I'm talking about
something else yeah all right
uh confabulation first of all Define for
the jury confabulation and are we likely
to see that well some people call that
honest lying meaning you're not telling
the truth but you really believe you are
uh and I'd like to see that with Terry
you could very well see that with Terry
yes is that a frontal load problem it's
a frontal lobe problem combativeness
but where the judge has made a ruling
I have and you'll get equal time
combativeness
I don't know in this environment he'll
be openly combative I think he has
enough self-regulation that he'll
respect the order of the court and the
judge I don't I don't think he'll argue
with you or or uh uh be inappropriate in
his behavior I think again I think what
the jury will see is what appears to be
a very normal man
lack of insight yes is that a frontal
lobe problem yes
and and that means in respect to Terry
and ability to see
and what other people are seeing
I think in the end his inability to take
the perspective of others we sometimes
call that theory of mind to understand
what someone is thinking or what they're
feeling he has a difficult time doing
that he can do it for brief periods and
then he forgets it and he goes right
back to where he was how about missing
the central point
it depends what we're talking about if
we're talking about eyes given his
vocational history he very well
understands the central point in visual
issues if we're talking about the
reasons for his challenges and his
behavior he doesn't get it okay and I
don't know if I ever got this out though
is
neuropsychological counseling important
this is one last question
there's no psychological counseling
important for Terry
will he benefit from that yes okay
and just how will he benefit from that
what's how what's the benefit going to
look like
uh someone to talk to that he believes
understands him and hopefully along the
way helps him come up with some
solutions to be happier and live a
little more functionally
thank you for coming doctors
defendant
Mr Egan
thank you for your honor hello Miss Dr
Goldstein good afternoon it's good to
see you again
you testified previously that you've
read the depositions of the daughters of
Mr Sanderson is that correct
I believe I testify to that in my
deposition yes right and
in that uh reading
do you recall reading that Jenny the
youngest of the daughters did not feel
loved or nurtured by her father growing
up
as we sit here I don't recall it but I
don't have any reason to disagree okay
and then did you read that Mr Sanderson
was domineering and emotionally and
verbally abusive to Jenny and her mother
Tana
that was in the deposition yes okay and
then
Mr Sanderson uh placed a strong emphasis
on Discipline Do you remember reading
that yes and that he became frustrated
at his expectations were not met yes and
that this is all before the accident
correct correct and he uh after Jenny
graduated from high school she and her
father did not speak for 13 years do you
recall reading that correct and I think
he currently has some disagreement with
her as well yes
and uh Mr Sanderson is controlling and
relentlessly tries to mold Jenny do you
remember reading anything like that yes
okay and that he oversteps boundaries
that she sets yes
in the report uh that you've provided
that has been referenced
a little bit here you go over the
records that you reviewed and found
significant you put them in a kind of
um long
document where you describe what you
found in those records correct correct
sometimes I quote them exactly and I put
quote quotations sometimes I paraphrase
right and in the and it's and by the way
I do you have your report there with you
I do and then you have your deposition
transcript as well I do oh you do oh
great you're very prepared thank you I
am and uh so in the on page five I guess
it's page four and five of your report
which is uh an exhibit to that
deposition I noted that there were just
two records that you you noted
pre-incident uh one on July 30th 2013
and then one on March 6 2015. do you see
that correct okay and
um
and then I wanted to return to this
testimony I think you offered earlier
that
um
and correct me if I'm I'm offering a
misunderstanding
I believe you said that the primary or
at least an important part of Mr
sanderson's symptoms is emotional
regulation problems is that correct
correct would you say primary
problem I don't know if I said primary
but it's in that constellation of
frontal lobe problems okay and that's a
really a big part of what he's
struggling with is that correct correct
okay and uh
in in uh
some prior VA records which I believe
you read correct there were a lot of
them I understand but so the VA records
I have a correspondence from October 8
2020 to Mr Bueller the VA records were
provided to me after I evaluated Mr
Sanderson but before you took my
deposition okay got it and so in those
records for example uh that this one's
bait stamped
va1131 I don't know that you would have
it right in front of you don't expect
that but I'm wondering if you recall
this
um given that you were focused on
emotional regulation there was a record
I believe from 2009 in which a provider
mentioned that the patient Mr Sanderson
mentioned that he had noticed he was
easy to anger do you remember seeing
records like that yes and that he got
angry at his girlfriend's children
yes okay and uh
um he became angry when he was
discussing a fam family conflict yes
um and that uh he would get angry and
kind of defensive at first was his
affect
I don't remember that but I'll take your
word for it but I remember the first
part okay sure
and then uh
another comment was the patient's desire
to feel justified in his anger and stand
up for his girlfriend was also discussed
yes you remember that yes
okay and then another record says and
this one is from
I don't know if you noticed but these VA
records are kind of hard to follow
because they they don't start with the
date at the top they're just kind of a
lot of times they're hard to obtain you
have scrolling yes that is also true
so the um
uh another record from 2009 the patient
mentioned difficulty with anger
management do you remember that yes okay
and then
um
another note was that he has begun to
speak more directly about how he is
feeling but he still struggles with
self-disclosure he's self-focused rather
than other Focus do you remember that
yes and then
um
for example when asked how he feels he
often responds with I feel that she is
and then there's an ellipsis do you
remember that correct yeah so the focus
of the session was to help him identify
his responses and the associated
feelings and communicate those in less
blaming ways do you remember seeing that
correct to take responsibility for his
role in whatever conflicts we're current
right right
um and then another note
um the patient noted that his
interaction style and way of dealing
with people often quote get him into
trouble and he would like to gain
greater insight into his interpersonal
difficulties you remember that yes okay
this is all before the accident correct
uh
in another session he said he would like
to address anger issues and
interpersonal problems that he believes
affect his interactions do you remember
correct records like that yes patient
also has a recent number of stressors
which he appeared to minimize and is
also denying significant depressive
symptoms if you remember those sorts of
things correct the latter isn't again an
interpretation and we can go back and
look at it sometimes clinicians
perceive that a patient is more
depressed than the patient reports and
then you have to try to decide what to
do about that
right
um
okay I think I I think we've covered
those
um
there was another record beforehand
which has already been discussed that
February 2nd 2016 record just weeks
before this ski accident do you recall
talking about that yes I didn't see that
in this note here where you where you
noted things prior but perhaps it's
because you you didn't have them correct
I will note however that the two that
you did know are VA records
those are the ones I had okay so you
just didn't have all of them however I
had them okay got it and the February
2nd note in addition to saying that he's
getting old all of a sudden it says that
he no longer does things that he used to
do do you remember that correct okay
and do you remember that he was retired
for a number of years before the ski
accident
yes yeah I don't know six seven years at
least yeah and he so he wasn't managing
a business and those sorts of things
anymore correct correct
um he wasn't in the Air Force at that
time
correct he had no vocational
responsibilities as far as I was aware
right he had maintained his license he
told me but he wasn't working okay got
it
um
I believe you said that you're making no
judgment you have no opinion really
about his prior function you don't know
what it was correct well I know what it
was to the extent that we've talked
about it okay but I'm not making any
judgment as to his the the breadth and
scope of the things we've just talked
about how it impacted his everyday life
I don't have any opinion other than what
was reported to me that it wasn't
affecting his everyday life right and
you said earlier maybe it was higher
before the ski accident correct correct
but this function also could have been
the same and you wouldn't know correct
correct
um
have you testified previously that Terry
thinks he's the smartest guy in the room
yes
and so any little deficit whether it's
from his accident or for some from
something else or from normal aging
distresses him correct that's the Mind
part that I testified to earlier right
and
you say that relative to other people is
AG test exceptionally well I think is
the words used is that correct in terms
of his intellect
and neuropsychological abilities and
academic achievement
just basic functioning in a controlled
laboratory setting yes right and and
that is
um after the accident correct correct
did you see any neuropsychological
evaluations before the ant accident
I'm trying to remember I think he had
some testing before I'm trying to
remember but I could be wrong
okay I I know he had he had a battery of
tests in 2017 which would be after right
and he saw a speech pathologist but I
don't recall if when they when he was
scanned earlier before that period of
time whether he had some cognitive
testing or not right so you couldn't
take the post-accident evaluations and
compare them to Prior ones you didn't
have any prior ones no and but I have no
reason what I did was look at his 2017
versus mine and didn't see any
progression so I don't have any reason
to think that he has a progressive
illness in terms of his brain
functioning right
um
and I think you've said you've testified
that his overall cognitive functioning
is is not significantly impaired
relative to people of his same profile
is that right it's not impaired it's
better yeah
um
I believe you've also previously
testified that it's important that
um
to diagnose a concussion as close to an
accident as possible is that correct
correct impreferably biomedically
trained expert right and and that's
because
the more time between the accident and
the diagnosis the more time there is for
other contributing factors to kind of
Muddy your analysis is that correct
correct particularly pain right
and I guess while we're on that point do
you remember in that record that we've
we've pulled up there's a there's a
report from a Deer Valley person who
responded the first kind of responder to
Mr Sanderson Whitney Smith and we'll
hear from her later in the trial that
there was a box there in that report
that said concussion and it was not
checked did you see that correct okay
and did you see anything in her report
where she said he lost Consciousness no
okay
and I think you've made this clear but
just in case it's not you don't yourself
have any opinion about whether there was
a concussion you're just deferring to
the people that have diagnosed him in
the records correct correct right
um
and that would be the same as to sort of
a post-concussive syndrome or persisting
concussion symptoms correct well that
would be a little different okay because
the persistence would be based on
reports of his or others in regards to
his behavior so when he sees me the
kinds of things he reports are
consistent with people who have
persistent post-concussion meaning that
small group of people who don't recover
for reasons that we don't always
understand right I see it's because you
now you it's a little different because
now you've actually evaluated him
correct okay but
um isn't it true that you don't have any
opinion about who is responsible for the
accident correct correct I have nothing
to do with the accident right I mean you
haven't read Miss powter's deposition
analyze the evidence about the ski
accident anything like that correct
correct it he could have slipped and
fallen in the in the laundry room for
all I know it doesn't matter and he also
uh could have had this concussion from
himself causing
correct
sure and I guess anything's possible
um
did you note that uh I think you've
actually previously testified that he
actually reported feeling better a
couple weeks after the Collision is that
correct he did yes
and that
uh over time
his psychological state became the much
stronger driver of his problems than his
neuro neurological state is that correct
correct just so that the jury if I may
ask you to understand you can explain
that that's what we talked about a
minute ago the difference between what
the brain injury caused him in terms of
his frontal lobe or orbital frontal lobe
problems with emotional regulation and
anger and and hear what we're seeing
from the data you've provided is an
exacerbation of those problems to a
point where it's significantly
disrupting his life the second part of
it that you alluded to is his mind that
as time goes on he's more and more
unhappy and frustrated about what he
perceives to be the significant change
in his life and on that perceived to be
point
um you're taking this report from him
obviously that's seems like that's all
you can do is hear his self-report and
and
um understand that he's reporting this
change in function in this difficulty
coping is that correct correct and I've
read for example the deposition of the
woman who was with him for 18 months
before and then after I think the jury
has heard testimony about her opinions
but again these kinds of problems are
can only be found in observation we
don't have neuropsychological tests for
the kinds of problems that Terry
experiences it's real life that reflects
that and I think as the jury is hearing
he may well have had some of these kinds
of issues before that accelerated after
for reasons that I think are a
combination initially of pain and a
brain injury and his mind
and to stick with his perception uh for
a little bit longer I believe you've
testified before that
um the primary concern that he had about
the accident as he reported it to you
were the events after the Collision is
that correct
that's correct okay so he he felt like
he was abandoned on the slope and he
kind of obsessed about that is that
correct
correct okay
and that was driving anxiety and some of
these other emotional difficulties at at
what point driving it the day when I see
him yeah at the point you were talking
yeah the point I see him it's multiple
years after
and what drives it at that point is a
probably a combination of things not
just his perception that that he was
skied into and then uh the person who
skied into him lacked remorse or didn't
support him or I think that was kind of
his initial view of it but over time his
perception of his dysfunction in his
everyday life is became a much bigger
issue I think if if the person who
allegedly skied into him
apologized I don't think it would solve
his problems today okay so
did you testify previously that from his
view because this person skied into him
and didn't have the respect to stop and
help him or acknowledge the problem and
as time has gone on he's become
increasingly obsessed with this entire
issue correct and that
psychologically that's his biggest
problem right now obviously that was not
this moment right now meaning at the
time he took at the time I saw him I
mean chronologically I'm testifying
about the time I saw him right yes I
have had conversations with him since
then but I haven't testified about those
conversations right
I believe you've testified before that
he did not report to you that he had
felt a sudden decline in cognitive
function in the weeks before the
Collision is that correct correct but
there was that that record that we've
gone over and and you hadn't seen it yet
when you evaluated him about this this
change in being able to do things that
he liked to do a few weeks before the
Coalition is that right correct and
probably would have been
um fortuitous had I seen it because
maybe I'd be better prepared to tell you
what he would have told me about why he
said so the um
I think you've also previously testified
that this
um
obsessing over the accident is kind of a
self-fulfilling prophecy that's the
quotation from your your transcript here
that I'm reading do you recall that
correct and you say uh as time goes on
it maybe in part becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy because no one
sits him down and says hey look you had
some of these problems before the
accident as a catalyst but really not a
primary cause of some of your
difficulties you know do you recall
saying that correct and we were talking
in that case about for example his his
reports of problems with memory or new
learning which again the test data
suggests he's capable of doing those
things yeah and then uh I believe
uh you were aware of Dr Fong's
evaluation correct correct and Dr Fong
reported
um that she had
um received a report from Mr Sanderson
that he'd Fallen
a number of years after the accident hit
his head and was unconscious for 45
minutes do you recall that well I was in
court this morning when it came up and
as I sat in court I did not recall it
and I don't recall that we discussed it
in my deposition and so I'd want to know
the chronology of when that event
occurred
uh and uh the time I saw him so we could
go to your deposition at the page uh 58
and 59 is where we discussed it
so if you go to the bottom of page 58
um you see where the question starts you
see it right you're correct yes yes I
apologize no that's fine so you'd read
that this report had been made but you
had not received a report about that
correct correct he didn't tell me about
it and I didn't see any medical records
reflecting it right and you thought that
if it's that severe if he was out for 45
minutes that there should probably be a
medical record correct correct and we'd
have to consider the possible
contribution of that event
to his problems again the chronology I
still don't know
when he saw Dr Fong versus when he said
he had that accident yeah I can profit
you that it was Dr at the time of Dr
Fong's deposition he had reported it to
her and that was a few years ago but he
reported it to her as occurring before
this after the accident after the
student called that yeah yeah so that
would be after the skiing accident this
sounds like a Laurel and Hardy movie
here but after the skiing accident but
before he saw me right okay yeah it's
important information yeah I I don't I
really don't know anything about it and
he did not tell you about it correct
right
um
so it sounds like you made a couple
recommendations which you don't usually
do you said correct
correct I was asked to write a letter to
his treater at the VA for him and I
first checked with Council because I'm
not a traitor Council indicated that
would be fine and I sent a letter I
believe it was uh
in June of 2020 and you recommended
counseling for depression and anxiety
correct correct and part of that was you
you thought that if you could get some
of that under control you'd have a
better idea of actually what was going
on uh with these problems a better
understanding of the cause correct
correct because it's still not totally
clear correct a better understanding at
least of the variables that were
impeding him from at least returning in
part to the life that he had by his view
from before right and then you also
recommended I'm gonna butcher this it is
cleanest race a colon esterase
Inhibitors and and your one of your
I think uh neuropsychology record
reviewers questioned me about that
um
if you think someone has so call an
esterase Inhibitors we think uh slow
down the formation of plaques which
contribute to early aging of the brain
it's not clear that those plaques are
the cause of dementia
now we know maybe we were wrong about
this but if they do slow the process
down some
and so if his problems were in any way
Progressive meaning he had vulnerability
he had an accident excuse me made him
worse but now it's going to continue
progressing the cholinesterase inhibitor
was a reasonable uh prophylactic
something we might do and just to
protect him there were no side effects
from it but recommending that doesn't
mean that I thought his problems were
from Alzheimer's you just thought it it
may be from aging so let's give him this
just in case just in case right sure
because you recognize that's a
possibility
correct right
if you previously testified that you do
not have an opinion at all about the
cause of plaintiff's injuries
that's correct
I believe you've testified before and
this maybe you've already gone over a
little bit oh you need some more can I
get a little more of course thank you
just a cup would be fine
thank you very much
um
and by the way I believe that Mr
Sanderson reported that the fall that
we've been discussing that he reported
to Fong was the result of dehydration
because you just reminded me of that do
you recall that yes I recall because I
just looked at it
Okay so
um I think you previously testified that
Mr sanderson's self-perception was based
on his feelings and the conclusion these
conclusions he's drawn not that you've
drawn but he's drawn about the cause of
the accident correct correct and that
um his everyday functioning was not a
function of lack of intellect or lack of
memory
uh capacity for his age or a lack of
neuropsychological ability is that right
correct
and you told him that over time that uh
you felt like he had elevated himself to
a point
where any little thing
uh sorry he had elevated eye and let me
read this again I butchered it I told
him that over time I felt like he had
elevated himself to a point where any
little thing he had trouble remembering
or doing was in his mind the trigger
immediately caused frustration and was
attributed to the injuries from the
accident do you recall saying that yes
I believe you've also testified that
over time you say that maybe some of his
problem is from aging correct
sure when you hit 70
it your memory and other functioning
kind of go down at an accelerated rate
and that is the bigger problem is his
mindset about how his life has been
affected correct so let me just clarify
okay but you didn't say that I did say
that yes and and I'm just clarifying it
within that context not to be defensive
but that as I've already testified I
think you know there there's a brain
injury
and there's a mind injury
the Mind injury is is more emotional or
psychological in the sense of what his
mind chooses to think about those events
and subsequently his life and what's
happened and what I suggested was that
at the that moment in time
if I could help his mind look at his
life a little differently
than I think he would be he could
function quite a bit better he could
return to doing some of the things that
he had done before I I I don't think
it's going to change his personality
style which I think has been adversely
affected or at least as we've discussed
it Amplified as a consequence of this
frontal lobe injury
I believe you've testified before that
he has never told you that the issue is
that for him is that Miss Paltrow hit
him on purpose you recall testifying
about that yes
so in other words he never said I'm I'm
mad she did this on purpose it's
affecting me nothing like that correct
no no we've all been skied into at one
point or another living in Utah yeah and
in fact he's he said that he knows it
was an accident correct correct
and I think there was a little bit of
discussion earlier about speeds I think
it was kind of in a hypothetical you
have no opinion about how fast someone's
going you said 40 miles an hour or this
kind of thing you don't you don't know
what it was on that on the slopes that
day right correct what I was offering
was the nature of brain injuries today
I mean if you were moving 50 miles an
hour 300 years ago you were falling off
a cliff
so the brain we didn't have those kinds
of brain injuries so it's a fairly new
phenomena to try and understand injuries
to the brain that come from movement as
opposed to adverse blows to the outside
of the skull
and
um
this this probably has been
mentioned before but
um Mr Sanderson has been described by
Craig Ramon whose deposition I believe
you've read uh
as someone that could talk to a wall for
a few hours and have a pretty good
conversation something to that effect
you recall that yes
um I sometimes worry that that's that is
not me but do you
and yeah and that was before the
accident correct
correct and again we wouldn't you know
you'd have to ask the witness what he
meant by that because it could have been
a perfectly cogent conversation sure uh
where you just don't let anybody else
speak or it could have been a circular
irrational confabulating conversation
and I think that's what's pointed out is
he now speak he still speaks a lot
but now when he speaks he speaks in
circles and perhaps he didn't do that
before right but you don't know he he
could have done that before correct and
uh because of his talkativeness uh and
his anxiety he actually had to come back
and do a second and even maybe a third
day evaluation with you is that right
correct because he wouldn't stop talking
right and that wasn't a typical process
is that right it's usually one day it's
usually one or two days but it's not
uncommon for people with frontal lobe
injures okay to have two or three days
yeah because they they have to talk
about everything
I think I'm getting close to finishing
here
I think you testified earlier that you
focus
in your practice on children and their
psychology is that right in my clinical
practice Yeah two-thirds I think in my
deposition I said it's about 50 50 for
forensics but I in looking back on it
it's two-thirds in clinical practice at
least the adults I see
tend to be
um in two categories younger adults
people I followed growing up with
genetic disorders uh and any other group
of people with early onset dementia so
there is a more virulent uh form of
dementia that people get for reasons we
don't understand in their 50s and they
decline very quickly and typically pass
away in just a few years and you know so
is it fair to say you don't typically
evaluate someone of Mr sanderson's
profile in in a forensic setting or in a
clinical setting are you what's the
answer both ways in a forensic setting
yes okay
in a clinical setting not that often
because again
he goes to the VA or he goes people go
to IHC to their insurance provider I'm
an independent provider so I I might not
I could see somebody like him but
probably not
it's more likely that someone like Dr
siebers would see him
I think that's all my questions
appreciate it
sure I guess it's not now it's hey it's
ganging up it's two on one here
okay oh this is this is to clarify
um something that has come up a few
times but but maybe this stratification
or that I don't know if that's the right
term but the different categories of
traumatic brain injuries
you've described Mr sanderson's as mild
but there are mild moderate and severe
categorizations that people use is that
correct correct and those
categorizations so the jury understands
typically refer to the Damage Done to
the brain
not necessarily to the consequences of
that damage and it's a it's a paradox in
our field that often people with mild
brain injuries report more every day
problems than people with moderate to
severe brain injuries we don't
completely understand why that is we can
offer or proffer some ideas typically
people with mild brain injuries go right
back to their previous life but our
compromise and experience consequences
mild moderate to severe brain injuries
typically people have a long period of
recovery they don't return to normal
life but we don't really understand
again I've been a bit wordy here his
problem is a mild brain injury based on
Coma score based on a cram score based
on his presentation at the scene based
on the fact his skull wasn't broken he
didn't have a brain bleed it's a mild
injury and I think you said earlier that
the vast majority I can't remember if he
gave a percentage maybe even 90 plus of
these mild traumatic brain injuries
usually resolve
and don't have those persisting symptoms
is that correct based on patient report
that's correct and and we don't
understand that 15 to 20 percent
sometimes they have pre-existing
problems that are exacerbated by their
brain injury making it harder to recover
sometimes they're clean one owners don't
have any problem and it's hard to
explain sometimes they have other life
stresses that that intermix with their
brain injury sometimes they have other
issues that have nothing to do with
their brain injury and in particular
often they have chronic pain
in patients with chronic pain over time
when it doesn't remit will report a
consolation of symptoms that are very
identical to post-concussion
but it's pain related
when Mr Sanders Sanderson has spoken to
you about the accident
um has he
discussed it
um whether his understanding of it comes
mainly from Mr Ramon or whether he has
specific memories of it himself I
haven't had that conversation with him
other than he telling me every time I've
spoken to him over the last
three years that he just remembers
somebody standing over him screaming at
it even when I haven't asked him about
it he's told me about it I see okay
that's all I have thank you
oh and that was a male skiing ski patrol
or ski instructor
I don't know who that was I mean he's
just he told me that's who it was but I
don't have an independent knowledge of
who that person was standing over him
right
figured that's what you told me and you
don't know the sex of that person no
okay
Mr Sykes any follow-up
I've got a very few questions I think
the jury's going home early tonight
would appear
Dr Goldstein
uh
you and I had a discussion about whether
Terry should be in the courtroom during
this trial did we not correct what's
your advice what was your advice
to Terry my advice was that he shouldn't
be in the courtroom why
uh I think he would have trouble
listening to people say things about him
that he disagreed with you're
interrupting but I'm just Gathering
what's going on I believe this is beyond
the scope and it's the news
all right
um
do you think Terry would have trouble
being in the courtroom
uh based on your your knowledge of Terry
uh how does he take
hearing criticism of himself not well
all right
um
now he talked about this
fall and I think the only place you saw
the
45-minute loss of conscience was in Dr
Fong's deposition is that right correct
okay uh there are no other reports
by Terry to anyone else about that
well I I don't know what I don't know
yeah I only know there are no other
reports in whatever materials I've been
provided you've read okay are there any
medical records that reporter not that
I've seen uh is that an example of
confabulation where you think something
happened but it didn't
could be
uh
and uh tell us very briefly
what the second and there's no medical
records to support that as far as you
know right
as far as I'm aware correct
um tell the jury briefly what the second
injury syndrome is
and brain injury yeah
it's beyond this code yeah but you know
I was shortened and honors no I'm asking
I need to have a question is is this
question relate to the 45-minute report
of loss of consciousness uh yes okay
overruled
go ahead so we're talking about
a colloquial term what happens to people
who have an injury and then have another
injury on top of that injury yes whether
it's any part of the body yes but here
we're talking specifically about an
injury to the brain and then a second
injury to the brain yes later
yeah the folklore is that the second
injury will be more symptomatic more
impairing harder to recover from because
of the vulnerability created by the
first injury it's very difficult to do
that research because it's hard to find
people other than athletes who have
chronic concussions over time now we're
testing people like that at some point
we'll be able to demonstrate that their
cognitive functioning after a second
injury is more impaired than a first or
a third or a fourth and again it's the
nature of the injury if your first
injury was very severe and your next one
was mild that would be different than it
was vice versa we just don't know
okay lastly
I'm going to show you what I'm going to
propose with the exhibit 43 plaintiffs
it's going to ask you to identify it
before I move the habit
it's okay so say 43 43.
uh and this is kind of
marked up awkward substitute
not sure what that is
oh I'm sorry
it's a cut and paste
did you already understand cut and paste
I think we all do nowadays it's a cut
and paste table from the computerized
printout that's used to score the
comprehensive executive functioning
inventory which is the questionnaire
that I testified to that I've developed
that is standardized on the general
population and I think we've briefly
talked about it earlier and it's again
it's executive functioning which we
talked about even earlier which is how
you do what you do so you get a single
score and it's made up of nine different
kind of behaviors that our research
demonstrated are the nine most common
kinds of strategies or behaviors people
use to function effectively in everyday
life okay and this is your test that you
developed in use worldwide it is and
this is the report of it correct in your
in your report that was
circulate to everybody in the case right
it's in it's in the body of my report it
appears on page 20 of my report I don't
know if my report's been admitted as a
it hasn't okay so this is Page 20 from
uh that report I don't remember how many
pages that report is in total so you're
all right I moved to have that admitted
it's exhibit to 43p
sure
Dr goldstein's is exhibit 43p
illustrate and demonstrate your
testimony by executive functioning
I don't understand the question
does it he talked earlier about some of
these findings correct does this
demonstrate the findings on Executive
function that we discussed on this
particular instrument yes based upon Mr
sanderson's self-reports yes comparing
those self-reports to a census match
sample yes of people his age and
educational background yes yes okay
your honor we would move to admit uh
exhibit 43 as a demonstrative
exhibit
may I see it
again we would substitute
and this one is all marked up by me but
we would give you a clean copy tomorrow
the charge or the the just the chart
yeah so here it is
all right so the chart itself not the um
the narrative that's above the chart oh
exactly that's part of the
but I would I would take that out if
there's a problem with that but this is
illustrative of his testimony yeah I
think it would be it's like repeating
someone's testimony in an exhibit so
I'll receive exhibit 43p for
demonstrative purposes
um which is the part that's on the on
the uh conditionally that you that you
submit to the court uh clerk the the
table portion of it as exhibit 43p okay
and I will strike out of the paragraph
correct all right do that tomorrow thank
you
receive different than the word admit
it's received as a demonstrative exhibit
in that category it's admitted as a
demonstrative exhibit both okay
okay objecting on
okay thank you I have one final question
excuse me and
the paragraph that is being excluded
explains what the scores mean
so so I have some concern that someone
looking at this will not have any way of
understanding it but may just read this
one classification which isn't a good
way of using the table but I'll respect
the Court's decision
paragraph explains what the scores mean
well I've made my ruling will um we can
resolve this once the jury's excused
sure thank you your honor thank you one
final question uh you mentioned 15 to 20
percent almost the last question asked
by uh Mr James over here what do you
mean by that is Terry in the 15 to 20
that don't recover yes okay thank you go
for the questions
Mr Egan
Dr Goldson you were asked about
um
that Dr Fong injury
report and then also this term that I'm
forgetting but uh it's a
it's supposed to describe how a second
injury might you know compound a first
right it wasn't my term it was council's
term I didn't use that term got it okay
um do you recall in reviewing Mr
sanderson's medical history that he had
a head injury when he was 10 years old
yes okay thanks
anything else
he functioned fairly well did he not
throughout his entire life until the ski
accident
sustained as to Leading
how did he function based on what you
know of him from age 10 until age 69.
function vocationally uh personally what
all the above they function like a high
like an accomplished individual who
obtained Advanced degrees worked at a
high level of White Collar work was
successful in business uh married a
number of times had children there was
no indication that he was any different
from anyone in the general population
okay maybe Superior to them in some
areas he was more advanced than them yes
I wouldn't use the word Superior more
advanced thank you
this question is that
um
all that information about marriages
work life that kind of stuff that's all
from Mr sanderson's self-report is that
correct
correct I I haven't looked at his
vocational history or his service
records or I can only rely on what he
reports to me right
okay
any other Witnesses for today Mr Sykes
um well we do but there's not enough
time treasure I just want to keep it
jury late which I don't want to do uh we
can handle her in about 20 minutes but
we'll we'll call her tomorrow
okay thank you so we will recess at this
time until 9 A.M tomorrow and I think
the if you arrive maybe 15 minutes early
that would be a good thing
thank you
I'm sorry I was thinking of something
else but let me just repeat an
admonishment to you before we we do
recess for the day I need to remind you
of the following instruction
please do not discuss the case with
anyone including other jurors please
don't attempt to learn anything about
the case outside of the courtroom
including from other jurors please avoid
radio TV the internet and newspaper
reports on this case please keep an open
mind throughout the presentation of the
evidence and finally please don't form
or Express an opinion on this case until
such time as it is finally submitted to
you for deliberations
so have a nice evening thank you
foreign
so looking at 43p
um
I mean it's a demonstrative exhibit
so any use of this will at from this
point forward will be either a witness
explaining what it means or counsel in
closing argument explaining what it
means and they would have access
obviously to the explanation information
so that at least the lawyer would
understand how it's to be presented to
the jury
does that resolve any issues that that
we might have concerning are you
concerned about this uh demonstrative
exhibit first of all you're the one
offering it as the court has received it
in terms of just the table proportion
well I I think that the paragraph
his explanatory of the table I like to
have the whole thing admitted as
demonstrative
uh but normally a a demonstrative
exhibit would be a chart or table that
sort of summarizes and helps explain the
testimony it seems like this is part of
the charter table and that's why I but
you know your honor if you're
uncomfortable with it
well I just don't recall him saying any
of that
that's in that explanation yeah
well in other words it would be
admitting hearsay as opposed to
illustrating his existing testimony
I I I disagree with that but you have
the black row not me and so I think it
helps explain
the uh the the chart and it should be in
it's not going to go back with a jury
apparently uh it's demonstrative I'd
like to use an enclosing argument
uh so I think the whole thing should
come in for that reason okay
and what's the defense's position on it
yeah you're on right I I just Echo what
you said which is that the paragraph I
believe was not offered as testimony and
would therefore be hearsay would not be
included or the numbers okay we don't I
mean I guess I could say also that Dr
Goldstein did not necessarily go through
all of these numbers and explain the
table and frankly I'm not totally uh
clear on exactly all what it means
because we didn't go through it it
wasn't even referenced until the very
end well I I guess I'm comfortable with
the fact that he did adopt the the
the um the table portion of this exhibit
well he adopted the whole thing but he
I'm comfortable with the fact that he
did adopt it
during his testimony I think that's
sufficient to allow it to be used for
demonstrative purposes it was referred
to generally throughout the testimony
and so if you can clean it up take out
the top paragraph at least what you'll
show to the jury from a demonstrative
standpoint should just be the the table
and the lawyers or other witnesses will
do with it what they can but then your
honorable that is shown as a
demonstrative exhibit we can explain
what it says in the paragraph to how to
read it right we're not prohibited from
talking about the first paragraph it
won't be shown to the jury but there's
got to be some explanation on how to how
to interpret it I mean if the lawyer
if you're talking about closing argument
exactly if there aren't
I don't know the answer that question
until I hear the argument but if the
argument is supported by evidence that
was admitted in court you can certainly
make the argument
do feel like we got broadsided on this
your honor it was beyond the scope I
didn't know this was going to be
suddenly like their centerpiece exhibit
on the last one minute or we would have
talked a lot more about it uh we can't
just cut and paste a thing and as the
last question say move to admit this we
shouldn't be able to do that with our
expert either
he didn't go by through this line by
line
well the decision was made it was
admitted you did have the opportunity to
re-cross on it so I'll the the decision
will stand so thank you
oh thank you Dr Goldstein Dr Goldstein
certainly
can be released
an observation sure what I worry about
is the author of that instrument is that
people will misunderstand it
and part of the reason we have so many
columns there some of them are numbers
some of them are verbal descriptions
we're looking at the same data in
multiple ways and I I just I as the
author of the instrument I want to make
sure that it's not misused that's my
only point and even that paragraph above
to a lay person doesn't provide enough
explanation for why do you call that a
weakness